programming throwdown episode 51 udacity democratizing education take it away patrick all right we're here with art Gillespie at Udacity HQ in this awesome room of soundproofing. This is like the most professional interview we've ever done for a podcast. Normally we're just like in our pajamas on the couch, like me at my house, Jason at his. I'm hoping he's wearing pajamas. Sometimes.
programming throwdown episode 51 udacity democratizing education take it away patrick all right we're here with art Gillespie at Udacity HQ in this awesome room of soundproofing. This is like the most professional interview we've ever done for a podcast. Normally we're just like in our pajamas on the couch, like me at my house, Jason at his. I'm hoping he's wearing pajamas. Sometimes.|||Programming Throwdown 第 51 期：Udacity，普及教育。帕特里克，开始吧。好的，我们现在在 Udacity 总部的阿特·格莱斯皮（Art Gillespie）办公室，在一个隔音效果超赞的房间里。这简直是我们为播客做过的最专业的一次采访。通常我们都穿着睡衣坐在沙发上，比如我在自己家里，杰森在威家。我希望他穿着睡衣。有时吧。
Depends if we're streaming or on live coding. Okay, anyways, we'll just keep moving forward. No bad pictures in our heads. Anyways, so we're here with Art. And Art, why don't you go ahead and introduce yourself? Hi, I'm Art Gillespie. I'm the Director of Engineering here at Udacity. And I keep wanting to make a joke about how I am not wearing pajamas right now.
Depends if we're streaming or on live coding. Okay, anyways, we'll just keep moving forward. No bad pictures in our heads. Anyways, so we're here with Art. And Art, why don't you go ahead and introduce yourself? Hi, I'm Art Gillespie. I'm the Director of Engineering here at Udacity. And I keep wanting to make a joke about how I am not wearing pajamas right now.|||这得看我们是在直播还是在进行实时编码。好吧，总之，我们继续往下聊。脑子里别想那些不健康的画面。总之，我们今天请到了阿特。阿特，要不你先自我介绍一下？嗨，我是 Art Gillespie。我是 Udacity 的工程总监。我一直想开个玩笑，说我其实没穿睡衣。
He's not wearing pajamas, that's true. But I am wearing clothes. So yeah, I've been the Director of Engineering here at Udacity for about a year now. And so I'm the hiring manager for engineers here. And yeah, I'm excited to talk to you guys. Nice. Very cool, very cool. All right, well, I think, Jason, you had some questions kind of prepared here.
He's not wearing pajamas, that's true. But I am wearing clothes. So yeah, I've been the Director of Engineering here at Udacity for about a year now. And so I'm the hiring manager for engineers here. And yeah, I'm excited to talk to you guys. Nice. Very cool, very cool. All right, well, I think, Jason, you had some questions kind of prepared here.|||他没穿睡衣，这倒是真的。但我确实穿着衣服。所以，是的，我担任 Udacity 的工程总监大约有一年了。我是这里的工程招聘经理。很高兴能跟你们聊聊。太棒了。很酷，非常酷。好的，杰森，我记得你好像准备了一些问题。
Do you want to? Sure. So some of these are kind of questions kind of for everyone, and we can go around the table and have a discussion about it. And so we're going to start off with one of those, which is, so Art, you have a background in engineering? I do. So how did you first learn how to program? Oh, it was a long time ago. So when I was 10, we got an Apple II at the school library.
Do you want to? Sure. So some of these are kind of questions kind of for everyone, and we can go around the table and have a discussion about it. And so we're going to start off with one of those, which is, so Art, you have a background in engineering? I do. So how did you first learn how to program? Oh, it was a long time ago. So when I was 10, we got an Apple II at the school library.|||你想来吗？当然。这些问题有些是适合每个人的，我们可以围坐在一起讨论。我们先从其中一个开始：阿特，你有工程背景吗？是的。那你最初是怎么学会编程的？哦，那是很久以前的事了。我 10 岁的时候，学校图书馆里有了一台 Apple II。
And I just started, I kind of borrowed the manuals and took them home and read them and I was I was writing like video game ripoffs cool early as I can remember and but I actually didn't realize you could get a job so I went on as I got older I went on to to go to business school and and kind of went that road and then came back to engineering by a long and winding route. So I am not a trained engineer. Okay, very cool, very cool. Yeah, personally, I was very similar.
And I just started, I kind of borrowed the manuals and took them home and read them and I was I was writing like video game ripoffs cool early as I can remember and but I actually didn't realize you could get a job so I went on as I got older I went on to to go to business school and and kind of went that road and then came back to engineering by a long and winding route. So I am not a trained engineer. Okay, very cool, very cool. Yeah, personally, I was very similar.|||然后我就开始借了说明书带回家阅读，我那时候就在写类似山寨电子游戏的程序，这是我最早的记忆了。但我当时其实并不知道写这个还能当工作，所以随着年龄增长，我去读了商学院，走了那条路，最后才通过一条曲折漫长的道路回到了工程领域。所以我不是科班出身的工程师。好的，非常酷，非常酷。是的，就我个人而言，经历也很相似。
I got a Commodore 64 from my parents, and it came with a manual that actually taught you BASIC. It's kind of wild. I mean, now you wouldn't even get a manual, I guess. It would just come with a PDF on it or something. But it had this very well-ill illustrated manual teaching basic and yeah I made you know tic-tac-toe and some kind of simple things on that and similarly you know my I remember my parents saying you know look computer programmers are just gonna be like TV repairmen right now I mean exactly doing this like go into
I got a Commodore 64 from my parents, and it came with a manual that actually taught you BASIC. It's kind of wild. I mean, now you wouldn't even get a manual, I guess. It would just come with a PDF on it or something. But it had this very well-ill illustrated manual teaching basic and yeah I made you know tic-tac-toe and some kind of simple things on that and similarly you know my I remember my parents saying you know look computer programmers are just gonna be like TV repairmen right now I mean exactly doing this like go into|||我从父母那里得到了一台 Commodore 64，它附带一本真正教你 BASIC 语言的说明书。这挺疯狂的。我的意思是，现在你可能连说明书都没有了，估计就给个 PDF 什么的。但当时那本说明书图文并茂地教 BASIC，然后我在上面做了一些井字棋（tic-tac-toe）之类简单的小东西。同样地，我还记得我父母当时说：“看吧，计算机程序员以后就会像修电视机的工人一样。”我的意思是，他们就是这么觉得的，不如去学|||
math like your dad and things like that and and uh it's amazing sort of how far we've come and now we realize that that that programming engineering these disciplines are just like incredibly valuable and uh uh and so it's amazing coming thinking all the way back to then and now what a huge difference right but but for me that's it was just um um i just serendipitously had a basic programming book that came with the computer and that's kind of how it started for me yeah my story is completely different um so both my father and my grandfather were computers and programming computers and so from a young age i didn't get we had computers around the house since you know my dad would you would, you know, get them and have them.
math like your dad and things like that and and uh it's amazing sort of how far we've come and now we realize that that that programming engineering these disciplines are just like incredibly valuable and uh uh and so it's amazing coming thinking all the way back to then and now what a huge difference right but but for me that's it was just um um i just serendipitously had a basic programming book that came with the computer and that's kind of how it started for me yeah my story is completely different um so both my father and my grandfather were computers and programming computers and so from a young age i didn't get we had computers around the house since you know my dad would you would, you know, get them and have them.|||数学，就像你爸爸那样之类的话。呃，一路走来，我们取得了多么惊人的进步啊，现在我们意识到编程、工程这些学科具有难以置信的价值。回想当年和现在，变化真是太巨大了！但对我来说，就是……我非常偶然地得到了一本随电脑附送的基础编程书，我的编程之路就是这样开始的。是的，我的故事完全不同……呃，我的父亲和祖父都从事计算机工作并编写程序，所以从小到大——家里一直都有电脑，你知道的，因为我爸会弄到并拥有它们。
And then he had programming books because he was doing programming. And so about the time I ever started getting interested, I could pick up one of his programming books, you know. What is it? Richie's C language book, you know, had that like on the shelf, like pick it up and look at it. So there's like a, it's pretty unique. You're a programming dynasty. Something like that. And so your first programming book was literally knr i won't say that i first understood it but it had to have been one of the first ones i picked up and
And then he had programming books because he was doing programming. And so about the time I ever started getting interested, I could pick up one of his programming books, you know. What is it? Richie's C language book, you know, had that like on the shelf, like pick it up and look at it. So there's like a, it's pretty unique. You're a programming dynasty. Something like that. And so your first programming book was literally knr i won't say that i first understood it but it had to have been one of the first ones i picked up and|||而且因为他在编程，所以他有很多编程书。所以当开始产生兴趣的时候，我可以随手拿起他的一本编程书。比如什么？里奇（Dennis Ritchie）的 C 语言书，你知道的，就放在书架上，拿起来看看。所以这挺特别的。你出身于编程世家。差不多吧。所以你的第一本编程书真的是 K&R（《C程序设计语言》）吗？我不敢说我一开始就读懂了它，但它绝对是我最早拿起来翻阅的书籍之一。
looked at right um instead of the dickens he gives you the no it wasn't like that but yeah so i mean from a young age you know we had like i had ides and you know stuff that i could get my that my dad had gotten right and so um you know initially it's hard he didn't really teach me at the beginning like I would just kind of try to learn myself and kind of but then you know once I was ready you know he was able to help me when I would get stuck and stuff so that's kind of how I learned um and then even I took programming classes and starting in high school um very cool and so yeah that's how I started so if you had to start from scratch you know the men in black folks came with the light and just blinded all of us, right? How would you start learning about programming today?
looked at right um instead of the dickens he gives you the no it wasn't like that but yeah so i mean from a young age you know we had like i had ides and you know stuff that i could get my that my dad had gotten right and so um you know initially it's hard he didn't really teach me at the beginning like I would just kind of try to learn myself and kind of but then you know once I was ready you know he was able to help me when I would get stuck and stuff so that's kind of how I learned um and then even I took programming classes and starting in high school um very cool and so yeah that's how I started so if you had to start from scratch you know the men in black folks came with the light and just blinded all of us, right? How would you start learning about programming today?|||看过的，对吧？嗯……他没给你狄更斯，而是给了你这个。不，倒也不是那样。但总之，从小时候起，你知道的，我们就有——我有 IDE（集成开发环境），还有我爸弄到的那些东西。所以，嗯，一开始很难，他一开始并没有真正教我，我基本上是自己尝试着去摸索，但后来，一旦我准备好了，当我遇到困难时，他能帮我，这就是我学习的方式。然后甚至从高中开始我就上了编程课。非常酷。是的，这就是我的起步经历。那么，如果你必须从零开始——假设《黑衣人》里的人拿着闪光灯把我们所有人的记忆都抹去了，对吧？你今天会如何开始学习编程？
That's a good question. It seems like a great time to be an autodidact. You know, if it were today, there's just so many resources. And if all I wanted to do was learn, it's almost an embarrassment of riches. So I remember as I was getting back into it, MIT OpenCourse Word had just kicked off. And they had SICP and all this great stuff. So I felt like I could go back and get some of that academic.
That's a good question. It seems like a great time to be an autodidact. You know, if it were today, there's just so many resources. And if all I wanted to do was learn, it's almost an embarrassment of riches. So I remember as I was getting back into it, MIT OpenCourse Word had just kicked off. And they had SICP and all this great stuff. So I felt like I could go back and get some of that academic.|||这是个好问题。现在似乎是自学的好时代。你知道的，如果是在今天，有这么多的资源。如果我只想学习，这简直是资源过剩（幸福的烦恼）。我记得当我重新开始接触时，麻省理工学院开放式课程（MIT OpenCourseWare）刚刚启动。他们有 SICP（《计算机程序的构造和解释》）和所有这些好东西。所以我觉得我可以回去学习一些学术方面的内容。
But honestly, it was great intellectually. It was super stimulating. But it didn't really help me with my day-to-day work. So I guess what I tell high school kids, I go talk at schools and whatnot, honestly, I just tell people to open up their browser, Google Chrome DevTools, and just start hacking. I mean, it's almost like everybody that has a computer has that Commodore 64 now because you have a full runtime right there in your browser, and you can just start writing games or whatever, and it's incredibly powerful.
But honestly, it was great intellectually. It was super stimulating. But it didn't really help me with my day-to-day work. So I guess what I tell high school kids, I go talk at schools and whatnot, honestly, I just tell people to open up their browser, Google Chrome DevTools, and just start hacking. I mean, it's almost like everybody that has a computer has that Commodore 64 now because you have a full runtime right there in your browser, and you can just start writing games or whatever, and it's incredibly powerful.|||但老实说，这在智力上很棒，超级具有启发性。但它对我的日常工作并没有太大帮助。所以我想我对高中生——我去学校演讲时——老实说，我只会告诉大家：打开你的浏览器，使用 Google Chrome 开发者工具（DevTools），然后开始折腾吧。我的意思是，现在几乎每个拥有电脑的人都拥有了当年那台 Commodore 64，因为你的浏览器里就有一个完整的运行时环境，你可以直接开始编写游戏或任何东西，这极其强大。
So that's what I tell young people is just find a know, find a text editor and start writing stuff in JavaScript. And it's a great way to learn. But for people like me that are doing a career change, I don't think there are as many good options. Because especially if you're looking to make the career change and you want some kind of credential or whatnot. And I think that's where, you know, Udacity sort of fits in is that specific market of people that aren't going to take three months off and go to a boot camp or, you know, stop and go back and get their graduate degree in, you know, computer science. So that, you know, obviously, I would recommend for those people, definitely take a look at us or, you know, other, you know,
So that's what I tell young people is just find a know, find a text editor and start writing stuff in JavaScript. And it's a great way to learn. But for people like me that are doing a career change, I don't think there are as many good options. Because especially if you're looking to make the career change and you want some kind of credential or whatnot. And I think that's where, you know, Udacity sort of fits in is that specific market of people that aren't going to take three months off and go to a boot camp or, you know, stop and go back and get their graduate degree in, you know, computer science. So that, you know, obviously, I would recommend for those people, definitely take a look at us or, you know, other, you know,|||所以我对年轻人说的是，找一个——你知道的，找一个文本编辑器，开始用 JavaScript 写点东西。这是学习的绝佳途径。但对于像我这样想要转行的人来说，我认为并没有那么多好的选择。因为特别是如果你想转行，并且想要某种凭证之类的东西。我认为这就是 Udacity 的切入点——它针对的是这样特定的群体：他们不会请假三个月去参加训练营，或者停下手头的工作回去拿一个计算机科学的研究生学位。所以，你知道的，显然我会向这些人推荐：一定要来看看我们，或者其他……
people in this sort of MOOC space. You guys said MOOC a lot in the debugging episode. We did. Yeah, we're a big fan of MOOCs. Definitely. Cool, cool. I'm very similar. I think the cool thing about JavaScript and the web is it's
people in this sort of MOOC space. You guys said MOOC a lot in the debugging episode. We did. Yeah, we're a big fan of MOOCs. Definitely. Cool, cool. I'm very similar. I think the cool thing about JavaScript and the web is it's|||MOOC（大型开放式网络课程）领域的其他人。你们在调试那一期里说了好多遍 MOOC。我们确实说过。是的，我们非常喜欢 MOOC。肯定的。酷，酷。我的看法很相似。我认为 JavaScript 和 Web 的酷炫之处在于，它
very easy to deploy. I think a lot of where people get stuck is where they don't get any feedback. They're learning C and they end up with loops and they have something that looks kind of cool to them, but they don't even know how to give it to somebody else. Maybe they're on a Windows, they're on a Mac or something like that. But you can just make a website with a JavaScript, a game, maybe tic-tac-toe where you click on the boxes. You could have that up and running, zero to 60 in to 60 in a few days and share that with the whole world.
very easy to deploy. I think a lot of where people get stuck is where they don't get any feedback. They're learning C and they end up with loops and they have something that looks kind of cool to them, but they don't even know how to give it to somebody else. Maybe they're on a Windows, they're on a Mac or something like that. But you can just make a website with a JavaScript, a game, maybe tic-tac-toe where you click on the boxes. You could have that up and running, zero to 60 in to 60 in a few days and share that with the whole world.|||非常容易部署。我认为很多人卡壳的地方在于他们得不到任何反馈。他们学习 C 语言，写出循环，做出他们觉得挺酷的东西，但他们甚至不知道怎么把它拿给别人看。也许他们在用 Windows，也许在用 Mac 之类的。但你只需要用 JavaScript 做一个网站、一个游戏，比如点格子玩的井字棋。你可以在几天内从零到精通（zero to 60）把它跑起来，并分享给全世界。
It's just very special. And I agree. I think I would start, just get Chrome, open up the dev tools, just start hacking away at it, totally. What about you? If you had to start over again, Patrick? Maybe I'm different than you guys.
It's just very special. And I agree. I think I would start, just get Chrome, open up the dev tools, just start hacking away at it, totally. What about you? If you had to start over again, Patrick? Maybe I'm different than you guys.|||这真是太特别了。我完全同意。我想我会从安装 Chrome、打开开发者工具开始，直接动手折腾，完全赞同。你呢？帕特里克，如果你必须重新开始的话？也许我和你们不太一样。
I don't know, the web stuff is cool, but I think today the biggest opportunity that would make me interested is the Arduinos and the hardware stuff, right? You get a Raspberry Pi, to some extent that's still just a computer, but something like an Arduino where it's really meant to hook up to sensors, to your world, right? That's cool to me, the whole just a step below robotics, I guess, but leading into that as an entry point, I think to me would be very enticing because you can write code and it's not just see something move around on the screen
I don't know, the web stuff is cool, but I think today the biggest opportunity that would make me interested is the Arduinos and the hardware stuff, right? You get a Raspberry Pi, to some extent that's still just a computer, but something like an Arduino where it's really meant to hook up to sensors, to your world, right? That's cool to me, the whole just a step below robotics, I guess, but leading into that as an entry point, I think to me would be very enticing because you can write code and it's not just see something move around on the screen|||我不知道，Web 东西很酷，但我认为今天最能引起我兴趣的巨大机会是 Arduino 和硬件相关的东西，对吧？你买个树莓派（Raspberry Pi），从某种程度上讲它依然只是一台电脑，但像 Arduino 这样真正用来连接传感器、连接你的真实世界的东西，对吧？这对我来说太酷了，它离机器人技术仅一步之遥，我认为以它作为切入点会非常诱人，因为你可以编写代码，而不单单是看到屏幕上的某个东西在移动
which is you know I could do with my paint tool on the screen as well right but you know actually seeing something move in the real world without a human doing it like to me I think I would find and I still do now even when I find myself with hobby time programming like that's the stuff I tend to program for and then as far as like learning from there so like starting up those things are cheap now I mean our doing is used to be I guess to me as like a student they were kind of expensive now you know you bought nine dollars right I don't know they're that expensive but I was gonna say even like $30 right like
which is you know i could do with my paint tool on the screen as well right but you know actually seeing something move in the real world without a human doing it like to me I think I would find and I still do now even when I find myself with hobby time programming like that's the stuff I tend to program for and then as far as like learning from there so like starting up those things are cheap now I mean our doing is used to be I guess to me as like a student they were kind of expensive now you know you bought nine dollars right I don't know they're that expensive but I was gonna say even like $30 right like|||——你知道的，我在屏幕上用画图工具也能做到这一点，对吧？但亲眼看到现实世界中的某个东西在没有人工干预的情况下自己动起来，对我来说，我发现——而且直到现在，当我利用业余时间编程时，这依然是我倾向于编写程序的领域。至于从那里开始学习，现在这些东西很便宜了。我的意思是，Arduino 以前，对我作为一个学生来说，可能有点贵。现在你知道的，9 美元就能买一个，对吧？我不知道它们是不是那么贵，但我是说甚至也就 30 美元左右，对吧？
it's really 25 30 yeah 25 30 you know that's fine you can do that but now I mean you can even get stuff that's like five dollars off Amazon in two days or whatever right like you know it's super super easy we won't get into like the authenticity of those or whatever but you? Like, you know, it's super, super easy. We won't get into like the authenticity of those or whatever, but you know, if you really want to do something, right? Like you can get that stuff and start there in the Arduino IDE and, you know, using that and they've made it, you know, to help you.
it's really 25 30 yeah 25 30 you know that's fine you can do that but now I mean you can even get stuff that's like five dollars off Amazon in two days or whatever right like you know it's super super easy we won't get into like the authenticity of those or whatever but you? Like, you know, it's super, super easy. We won't get into like the authenticity of those or whatever, but you know, if you really want to do something, right? Like you can get that stuff and start there in the Arduino IDE and, you know, using that and they've made it, you know, to help you.|||确实是 25 到 30 美元吧，是的，25 到 30 美元，你知道这没问题，你可以买得起。但现在我的意思是，你甚至可以在亚马逊上花 5 美元两天就能买到类似的东西，对吧？你知道的，这超级超级简单。我们先不讨论这些东西的正品山寨问题，但你知道的，如果你真的想做点什么，对吧？你可以买到那些东西，从 Arduino IDE 开始，使用它，他们已经把工具做得很完善来帮助你了。
And then I think the learning goes from how do I learn what programming is? And I think everything we described is kind of talking about how do we learn what programming is, except for maybe Udacity, which maybe you can fill this in a little. And that is a first step and you need to do that to find out is this interesting to me but i think one of the things that is for someone who's learning on their own is how do you transition from learning what programming is what a programming
And then I think the learning goes from how do I learn what programming is? And I think everything we described is kind of talking about how do we learn what programming is, except for maybe Udacity, which maybe you can fill this in a little. And that is a first step and you need to do that to find out is this interesting to me but i think one of the things that is for someone who's learning on their own is how do you transition from learning what programming is what a programming|||然后我认为学习的过程从“我如何了解什么是编程”开始。我想我们刚才描述的一切都在讨论我们如何了解什么是编程，除了 Udacity 之外（或许你可以稍微补充一下）。那是第一步，你需要通过它来弄清楚这对我来说是否有趣。但我认为，对于自学的人来说，其中一个关键问题是：你如何从学习“什么是编程”、“什么是编程
language is what does it mean how do i write stuff in it how do i make software right and and making a game in part teaches you that but how how do I structure things? So getting into things like what is OO? Architecture. Object oriented. What is, you know, what is this functional programming language? Like as people in that industry, we talk about those things and we have a feeling for what they mean. But I imagine as a newcomer, right, how do I go from essentially the scripting modality? Like I'm scripting things to happen.
language is what does it mean how do i write stuff in it how do i make software right and and making a game in part teaches you that but how how do I structure things? So getting into things like what is OO? Architecture. Object oriented. What is, you know, what is this functional programming language? Like as people in that industry, we talk about those things and we have a feeling for what they mean. But I imagine as a newcomer, right, how do I go from essentially the scripting modality? Like I'm scripting things to happen.|||语言”、“它意味着什么”、“我如何在其中编写东西”、“我如何制作软件”过渡到……制作游戏在某种程度上教会了你这些，但是——我该如何构建代码结构呢？因此，开始接触诸如什么是面向对象（OO）？架构。面向对象。什么是——你知道的，什么是这种函数式编程语言？作为这个行业的从业者，我们讨论这些事情，并且对它们的含义有着直觉。但我想作为一个初学者，对吧，我如何从本质上的脚本编写模式（比如我编写脚本让事情发生）
Maybe I add some input, but I'm doing that very simple flow. So how do I say I'm going to build a piece of infrastructure? I'm going to, you know, why would someone go work at X or Y Silicon Valley company just making pipes? Like why is that interesting to them? They're just taking data from one place and sticking in some other, you know. I'd rather make games or I'd rather make robots, right? But there are obviously intelligent people doing those things and like i think one of the missing things for self-teaching is how do you make that yeah that progression and that's something that you know i was forced to learn at university
Maybe I add some input, but I'm doing that very simple flow. So how do I say I'm going to build a piece of infrastructure? I'm going to, you know, why would someone go work at X or Y Silicon Valley company just making pipes? Like why is that interesting to them? They're just taking data from one place and sticking in some other, you know. I'd rather make games or I'd rather make robots, right? But there are obviously intelligent people doing those things and like i think one of the missing things for self-teaching is how do you make that yeah that progression and that's something that you know i was forced to learn at university|||也许我添加了一些输入，但我执行的是非常简单的流程。那么我该如何说“我要构建一个基础设施”？我要——你知道的，为什么有人会去某家硅谷公司工作，仅仅是为了造“管道”？这对他有什么吸引力？他们只是把数据从一个地方搬到另一个地方，你知道的。我宁愿做游戏或者做机器人，对吧？但显然有聪明人在做那些事情，而且我认为自学所缺少的一点就是：你如何实现这种——是的，这种进阶？这是我被迫在大学里学习的东西，
because you take a class and the teacher gets up and tells you like hey when you get to industry like they're going to be making you do these kinds of things here's an established code base like go in and make edit and i guess it's part of their curriculum there. Yeah. So that gets into our next question, is actually exactly this. So by far the most question, I'm sure everyone listening is dying to hear the answer from Art, is I got a degree in not CS, but I love programming. How can I get a job at programming?
because you take a class and the teacher gets up and tells you like hey when you get to industry like they're going to be making you do these kinds of things here's an established code base like go in and make edit and i guess it's part of their curriculum there. Yeah. So that gets into our next question, is actually exactly this. So by far the most question, I'm sure everyone listening is dying to hear the answer from Art, is I got a degree in not CS, but I love programming. How can I get a job at programming?|||因为你上了一门课，老师走上讲台告诉你：“嘿，当你进入工业界时，他们会让你做这些事情。这里有一个现有的代码库，进去进行修改吧。”我想这是他们课程的一部分。是的。这就引出了我们的下一个问题，正好就是这个。到目前为止，我相信所有在听节目录音的人都迫切想听到阿特回答的一个问题是：我拿的不是计算机科学（CS）学位，但我热爱编程。我怎样才能找到一份编程工作？
And that includes being able to do architecture and the basics and things like that. Yeah, and I think there are a lot of paths, really. As a hiring manager, I'll walk back. I'll start with the end of this answer and walk back. I think as a hiring manager, when people show up and they just show a big path. I mean, I don't really pay attention to CS degrees anymore as a hiring. It's been a few years since I really cared because I just didn't see any correlation. And I was getting a lot of people that had taught themselves or had made the change. And this is
And that includes being able to do architecture and the basics and things like that. Yeah, and I think there are a lot of paths, really. As a hiring manager, I'll walk back. I'll start with the end of this answer and walk back. I think as a hiring manager, when people show up and they just show a big path. I mean, I don't really pay attention to CS degrees anymore as a hiring. It's been a few years since I really cared because I just didn't see any correlation. And I was getting a lot of people that had taught themselves or had made the change. And this is|||这其中还包括能够做架构、基础知识以及诸如此类的事情。是的，真的有很多途径。作为一名招聘经理，我退一步讲。我从这个回答的结尾开始往前推。我认为作为一名招聘经理，当人们出现并展示出一条广阔的道路时……我的意思是，作为招聘方，我不再真正关注计算机科学学位了。我已经有好几年不在乎这个了，因为我根本没看出它们之间有什么相关性。而且我招到了很多自学成才或成功转行的人。这就是
sort of like part of my journey to Udacity is, you know, career wise is realizing this is a powerful thing that's happening where people aren't CS majors, but they're totally capable of doing industry work. And so I don't really pay attention to that. I look for a passion for the work. And I usually get a great signal. What we do here is we just do a ton of research on people's beforehand GitHub. Do they have a blog? What have they shipped on their own?
sort of like part of my journey to Udacity is, you know, career wise is realizing this is a powerful thing that's happening where people aren't CS majors, but they're totally capable of doing industry work. And so I don't really pay attention to that. I look for a passion for the work. And I usually get a great signal. What we do here is we just do a ton of research on people's beforehand GitHub. Do they have a blog? What have they shipped on their own?|||我加入 Udacity 心路历程的一部分，在职业生涯中我意识到正在发生一件很有力量的事：人们虽然不是计算机科学专业出身，但完全有能力胜任工业界的工作。所以我并不怎么关注学历。我在寻找对工作的热情。而且我通常能从中得到很好的信号。我们在这里做的是，对候选人之前的 GitHub 进行大量研究。他们有博客吗？他们自己发布过什么产品？
Because there's almost no excuse for not shipping something on your own. As you said, it's super easy to deploy just about anything. You can ship an app to the App Store. The cost is virtually nil. And so I always recommend to people that they build up a portfolio of projects. And this is sort of the tack that Udacity took at it as well, is that it's project-based curriculum.
Because there's almost no excuse for not shipping something on your own. As you said, it's super easy to deploy just about anything. You can ship an app to the App Store. The cost is virtually nil. And so I always recommend to people that they build up a portfolio of projects. And this is sort of the tack that Udacity took at and as well, is that it's project-based curriculum.|||因为几乎没有任何借口不去自己发布点东西。正如你所说，部署任何东西都超级简单。你可以将一个应用发布到 App Store。成本几乎为零。所以我总是建议人们建立自己的项目作品集（portfolio）。这也是 Udacity 采用的方法，即基于项目的课程体系。
And so you go through, you fix real projects, you build real projects from scratch. And, you know, we have an army of code reviewers that go through it. And, you know, you either meet expectations, don't meet expectations. And that's why we feel comfortable credentialing people at the end. Because they've gone through this sort of rigorous code review process on these five or six projects. But, you know, whether you do it at Udacity, whether you do it on your own, that's the key, I think,
And so you go through, you fix real projects, you build real projects from scratch. And, you know, we have an army of code reviewers that go through it. And, you know, you either meet expectations, don't meet expectations. And that's why we feel comfortable credentialing people at the end. Because they've gone through this sort of rigorous code review process on these five or six projects. But, you know, whether you do it at Udacity, whether you do it on your own, that's the key, I think,|||因此，你经历这些，修复真实的项目，从头构建真实的项目。而且，你知道，我们有一大批代码审查员（code reviewers）来审核，你会达到期望，或者达不到期望。这就是为什么我们有信心在最后为学员颁发证书。因为他们在这五六个项目上经历了如此严格的代码审查流程。但是，你知道，无论你是在 Udacity 做这件事，还是靠自己独立完成，这才是关键所在，我认为，
is having this demonstrated passion for the work that manifests itself in projects. So do you have a differentiation between people who do the shotgun approach? Like here I have a bunch of, and I don't mean this slanderously, but a bunch of toy apps, right? Like here I wrote another to-do app in JavaScript,
is having this demonstrated passion for the work that manifests itself in projects. So do you have a differentiation between people who do the shotgun approach? Like here I have a bunch of, and I don't mean this slanderously, but a bunch of toy apps, right? Like here I wrote another to-do app in JavaScript,|||那就是展现出对这份工作的热情，这种热情体现在项目中。那么，对于那些采用“散弹枪打鸟”（shotgun approach）的人，你会有所区别对待吗？比如，“这里我有一堆——我不是在贬低，但就是一堆玩具应用（toy apps）”，对吧？比如“我又用 JavaScript 写了一个待办事项（to-do）应用，
and then I wrote an iPhone game, but it's you know i move sprite it's a match three game that i found mostly the template on the internet right like so thinking about how i would look at hiring someone right and bringing them in is like to me that approach says something very different than this person kind of sat down and did something new or something different something where they had to get past the point of following in other footsteps and like kind of doing that learning where there isn't a clear guide right like they've been given the fundamentals but they have to go out and kind of do it from I don't know from scratch isn't the right word but kind of like build that thing which there wasn't an existence proof
and then I wrote an iPhone game, but it's you know i move sprite it's a match three game that i found mostly the template on the internet right like so thinking about how i would look at hiring someone right and bringing them in is like to me that approach says something very different than this person kind of sat down and did something new or something different something where they had to get past the point of following in other footsteps and like kind of doing that learning where there isn't a clear guide right like they've been given the fundamentals but they have to go out and kind of do it from I don't know from scratch isn't the right word but kind of like build that thing which there wasn't an existence proof|||然后我写了一个 iPhone 游戏，但你知道的，我只是移动了一下精灵（sprite），那是一个三消游戏，模板基本上都是从网上找的”，对吧？所以想想看，当我考虑录用某人并将其带进团队时……对我来说，这种做法所传达的信息，与另一个人坐下来做点新东西或与众不同的东西截然不同——那种他们必须超越“跟随别人的脚步”的阶段，在没有清晰指引的情况下进行学习（他们虽然掌握了基础知识，但必须走出去，从头开始——“从头开始”可能不太准确，但有点像构建那样一个此前并不存在现成证明的东西）的过程是完全不同的。
for well I would argue that the the signal I like best is actually that they went to a real project and just started contributing to it in a small fashion and not doing something from scratch and being hyper creative because I hardly ever hire people that I need to create something from scratch I need them to work on a code base and build features but it's a fair point if it is just sort of look I completed this tutorial obviously not that interesting but there are people that have taken tutorials and just gone insane and that's super impressive but yeah I mean a lot of times I'm actually looking are people that have taken tutorials and just gone insane. Right. And that's super impressive. But yeah, I mean, a lot of times I'm actually looking for people that have
for well I would argue that the the signal I like best is actually that they went to a real project and just started contributing to it in a small fashion and not doing something from scratch and being hyper creative because I hardly ever hire people that I need to create something from scratch I need them to work on a code base and build features but it's a fair point if it is just sort of look I completed this tutorial obviously not that interesting but there are people that have taken tutorials and just gone insane and that's super impressive but yeah I mean a lot of times I'm actually looking are people that have taken tutorials and just gone insane. Right. And that's super impressive. But yeah, I mean, a lot of times I'm actually looking for people that have|||嗯，我可以说，我最喜欢的信号其实是：他们参与了一个真正的项目，并以微小的方式开始做出贡献，而不是从零开始做一些超级有创意的东西。因为我几乎从不需要雇佣任何人来从头创造什么东西，我需要他们在现有的代码库上工作并构建功能。但你的观点也有道理，如果只是那种“看，我完成了这个教程”的心态，显然没那么有趣。不过确实有些人学了教程之后就疯狂深入研究，那超级令人印象深刻。但对，我的意思是，很多时候我其实在寻找那些学了教程却能玩出花样（gone insane）的人。对。那超级令人印象深刻。但对，我的意思是，很多时候我其实在寻找那些
contributed meaningfully to open source projects, even on smallish features. So what would you say, and obviously, specific examples, but like as a general case, what would be a significant contribution to an open source project? Oh, that's a good question. So like, obviously, a bug fix, right? Like, could be a scale from like, I went and changed one line of code. But that's still hard.
contributed meaningfully to open source projects, even on smallish features. So what would you say, and obviously, specific examples, but like as a general case, what would be a significant contribution to an open source project? Oh, that's a question. So like, obviously, a bug fix, right? Like, could be a scale from like, I went and changed one line of code. But that's still hard.|||对开源项目做出过有意义贡献的人，哪怕只是贡献了一些较小的功能。那么你会怎么说——当然最好有具体例子——但作为一个通用情况，对开源项目的重大贡献会是什么样的？哦，这是个好问题。比如，很显然，修复一个 bug，对吧？其规模可能从“我去改了一行代码”。但这依然很难。
You've got to figure out what line of code to change, right, to, like, adding a feature. Is it along that spectrum? How do you kind of, or what have you come across in the past? Well, I think, yeah, exactly. So if you're looking at an entry-level candidate, you know, somebody that's gone in and taken the initiative to, you know, find a bug or five or six and go through and fix them. And you can go through and you can see their comments on the bug group. This is an incredible signal that you don't normally get because somebody just has a four-year CS degree, right? So it's not so much, I mean, there
You've got to figure out what line of code to change, right, to, like, adding a feature. Is it along that spectrum? How do you kind of, or what have you come across in the past? Well, I think, yeah, exactly. So if you're looking at an entry-level candidate, you know, somebody that's gone in and taken the initiative to, you know, find a bug or five or six and go through and fix them. And you can go through and you can see their comments on the bug group. This is an incredible signal that you don't normally get because somebody just has a four-year CS degree, right? So it's not so much, I mean, there|||你必须找出究竟该修改哪一行代码，对吧？一直到添加一个新功能。它在这个光谱（spectrum）上延伸吗？你是怎么看的，或者你过去遇到过什么？嗯，我想，确实如此。所以如果你看一个入门级的候选人，你知道的，有个人主动去寻找一个或五六个 bug 并逐一修复它们。你还可以去查看他们在 bug 讨论组里的评论。这是一个极其惊艳的信号，而你通常无法从一个仅仅拥有四年制计算机科学学位的人身上得到这种信号，对吧？所以这并不完全是关于——我是说，那里
is an issue of scope there, right? If they just went in and fixed the readme and said, I contributed the Python, which people have definitely done. No, someone exaggerated on their resume? No. I know. It seems extra silly in this day and age
is an issue of scope there, right? If they just went in and fixed the readme and said, I contributed the Python, which people have definitely done. No, someone exaggerated on their resume? No. I know. It seems extra silly in this day and age|||存在一个范围（scope）的问题，对吧？如果他们只是进去修复了一下 readme（说明文档）就说“我为 Python 做出了贡献”，确实有人这么干过。不，有人在简历上夸大其词？没有。我知道。在这个时代，这显得格外愚蠢，
since all you have to do is go check the commitment list, right? But, yeah, no, it's not so much scope. It's more the nature of the work. And then, of course,
since all you have to do is go check the commitment list, right? But, yeah, no, it's not so much scope. It's more the nature of the work. And then, of course,|||因为你只需要去查一下提交记录（commit list）就行了，对吧？但是，是的，不，这与其说是范围问题，不如说是工作的性质。然后，当然了，
you're looking for all the sort of maybe softest skills, but like how do they communicate the issues that they run into? How do they participate in the community?
you're looking for all the sort of maybe softest skills, but like how do they communicate the issues that they run into? How do they participate in the community?|||你在寻找所有那些可能最软性的技能，比如：他们如何沟通自己遇到的问题？他们如何参与社区？
Because these are the things that are going to make and break them on your team, right? You know, so, yeah, it's not. And I've run into things where people showed up to, I don't want to get too specific, call people out.
Because these are the things that are going to make and break them on your team, right? You know, so, yeah, it's not. And I've run into things where people showed up to, I don't want to get too specific, call people out.|||因为正是这些事情决定了他们在你的团队中是成是败，对吧？你知道的，所以，是的，这并不……我曾遇到过这样的情况：有人出现来——我不想说得太具体去点名。
It's too easy to identify people. Sure, but. But where somebody went to an open source language project and basically had completely rewrote their support for AIFF files. And this was just because it was, and they improved the load. I don't remember. So AIFF files have the chunk of the header that has all the metadata,
It's too easy to identify people. Sure, but. But where somebody went to an open source language project and basically had completely rewrote their support for AIFF files. And this was just because it was, and they improved the load. I don't remember. So AIFF files have the chunk of the header that has all the metadata,|||太容易被人认出来了。当然，但是……但曾有人去参与一个开源语言项目，基本上完全重写了他们对 AIFF 文件的支持。这纯粹是因为……而且他们改进了加载方式。我记不清了。AIFF 文件有一个包含所有元数据的头部区块（chunk of the header），
and it improved parsing of that. It was like, I don't know, 80% or something. But, you know, I mean, to me that just shows a tremendous amount of initiative. And also they participated really well. And this is something that had like no prior experience, you know, they built some projects and whatnot. But that one thing was enough for me, you know, in the interview and whatnot, you know, they were capable. Yeah, that was enough for me. So I mean, when people are looking to make the change, I think there's a lot more fear of that process. You know, this town is kind of legendary for having crazy academic requirements
and it improved parsing of that. It was like, I don't know, 80% or something. But, you know, i mean, to me that just shows a tremendous amount of initiative. And also they participated really well. And this is something that had like no prior experience, you know, they built some projects and whatnot. But that one thing was enough for me, you know, in the interview and whatnot, you know, they were capable. Yeah, that was enough for me. So I mean, when people are looking to make the change, I think there's a lot more fear of that process. You know, this town is kind of legendary for having crazy academic requirements|||它改进了对该部分的解析。效率提升了大概，我不知道，80% 左右。但是，你知道，对吧，在我看来，这展现出了巨大的主观能动性。而且他们的参与度非常好。而这个人之前没有任何相关经验，你知道的，他们只是构建了一些项目之类的小东西。但就凭那一件事，对我和面试来说就足够了，你知道的，他们是有能力的。是的，这就足够了。所以我的意思是，当人们想要转行时，我认为他们对这个过程有着更多的恐惧。你知道的，这个地方（指硅谷）以拥有疯狂的学术要求
and insane interviews. But when in fact, we're just looking for great people. That's true. And I think too, it depends on, you know, the, the, the company. I think there are some very large companies that have, um, um, that, that get millions of resumes and, um, they don't, they're not going to be able to know who's passionate for the company and who's not. And so it might be difficult without a CS degree to get through all the autonomy so someone can find the diamond in the rough. Not impossible, but more difficult.
and insane interviews. But when in fact, we're just looking for great people. That's true. And I think too, it depends on, you know, the, the, the company. I think there are some very large companies that have, um, um, that, that get millions of resumes and, um, they don't, they're not going to be able to know who's passionate for the company and who's not. And so it might be difficult without a CS degree to get through all the autonomy so someone can find the diamond in the rough. Not impossible, but more difficult.|||和变态的面试而闻名。但事实上，我们只是在寻找优秀的人才。确实如此。我也觉得，这取决于——你知道的——公司。我认为有些非常大的公司，它们会收到数百万份简历，呃，它们无法分辨谁对公司充满热情，谁没有。因此，如果没有计算机科学学位，想要穿过层层自动化筛选让某人能够在一堆粗粝的沙子中发现你这块金子，可能会比较困难。并非不可能，只是更难。
But if you find a place like U udacity and uh you have sort of good synergy then there's there's there's no reason why uh you know you with you know the right github and these these kind of like experiences why your resume wouldn't get looked at i think that's a common fear is i'm going to give my resume, it's going to say GitHub superstar invented Lua, did all these things, but it's not going to have computer science degree from insert top five university here, and some filter is going to remove it. I think that happens.
But if you find a place like U udacity and uh you have sort of good synergy then there's there's there's no reason why uh you know you with you know the right github and these these kind of like experiences why your resume wouldn't get looked at i think that's a common fear is i'm going to give my resume, it's going to say GitHub superstar invented Lua, did all these things, but it's not going to have computer science degree from insert top five university here, and some filter is going to remove it. I think that happens.|||但如果你找到像 Udacity 这样地方，并且呃你们之间有很好的契合度，那么——没有任何理由——你知道的，凭借你正确的 GitHub 和这些诸如此类的经验，你的简历为什么不会被看一眼。我认为这是一个普遍的恐惧：我要递交简历了，上面会写着“GitHub 超级巨星，发明了 Lua，做了所有这些事情”，但它上面没有“来自某某排名前五大学的计算机科学学位”，然后某个过滤系统就会把它筛掉。我认为这种情况确实会发生。
I do think that it happens, but it's not as prevalent as people think. DAN GALPIN- Sure. Also, I was at Google for a while. If you're shooting for Google, this is probably a tougher road to go. But even,
I do think that it happens, but it's not as prevalent as people think. DAN GALPIN- Sure. Also, I was at Google for a while. If you're shooting for Google, this is probably a tougher road to go. But even,|||我确实认为这种情况会发生，但它并没有人们想象的那么普遍。丹·加尔平（Dan Galpin）——当然。另外，我在谷歌待过一段时间。如果你的目标是谷歌，这可能是一条更艰难的路。但即使如此，
didn't they just, and I think you guys mentioned it too, they had their how to become an engineer page. Oh, the Laszlo posted this, right? There was this list and like Udacity's on it
didn't they just, and I think you guys mentioned it too, they had their how to become an engineer page. Oh, the Laszlo posted this, right? There was this list and like Udacity's on it|||他们不是刚刚——而且我想你们也提到过——他们有那个“如何成为一名工程师”的页面吗？哦，拉斯洛（Laszlo）发过这个，对吧？上面有个清单，Udacity 也在上面，
and you know, how to become a software engineer. Nowhere on the list did it say go get a CS degree. Right. And so,
and you know, how to become a software engineer. Nowhere on the list did it say go get a CS degree. Right. And so,|||还有，你知道的，如何成为一名软件工程师。清单上的任何地方都没有说“去拿一个计算机科学学位”。对的。所以，
I don't know, maybe things are changing there as well. Yeah. But the, so that's really exciting to me that it's not, and because just if you think about, you mentioned the industrial revolution earlier, that if we think about the number of jobs that are going to require these skills and the number of people that have them,
I don't know, maybe things are changing there as well. Yeah. But the, so that's really exciting to me that it's not, and because just if you think about, you mentioned the industrial revolution earlier, that if we think about the number of jobs that are going to require these skills and the number of people that have them,|||我不知道，也许那边的情况也在发生变化。是的。但是，这让我感到非常兴奋，因为它不是——而且因为只要你想想，你刚才提到了工业革命，如果我们想想将需要这些技能的工作数量以及拥有这些技能的人数，
we probably have to find a different model. Yep. And just to recap, so we talked about this on the 50th episode, but in case you're skipping, there's this idea of sort of this pyramid where you just, at different levels of the pyramid, you have different roles and they're needed at different quantities. And the Industrial Revolution shifted that whole pyramid up where you need way more mechanists, not as many farmers, and just everyone kind of, all the other levels above farmer grew dramatically.
we probably have to find a different model. Yep. And just to recap, so we talked about this on the 50th episode, but in case you're skipping, there's this idea of sort of this pyramid where you just, at different levels of the pyramid, you have different roles and they're needed at different quantities. And the Industrial Revolution shifted that whole pyramid up where you need way more mechanists, not as many farmers, and just everyone kind of, all the other levels above farmer grew dramatically.|||我们可能必须找到一种不同的模式。是的。顺便总结一下，我们在第 50 期节目中讨论过这个，但如果你跳过了那一期，这里有个金字塔的概念：在金字塔的不同层级上，你有不同的角色，并且它们需要不同的数量。工业革命将整个金字塔向上推移了，你需要更多的机械师，不再需要那么多农民，除了农民之外的所有其他层级都急剧增长。
And so what we're seeing now in the information age is the potential for the pyramid to shift up again. And so that's where something like Udacity becomes very important. So just one thing to clarify and then a comment. So we're talking about Udacity both as a place to learn and a place to work. So that might be slightly confusing to some people. So it may be good to talk about Udacity as a place to work. You guys aren't just a shell website that hosts people's videos.
And so what we're seeing now in the information age is the potential for the pyramid to shift up again. And so that's where something like Udacity becomes very important. So just one thing to clarify and then a comment. So we're talking about Udacity both as a place to learn and a place to work. So that might be slightly confusing to some people. So it may be good to talk about Udacity as a place to work. You guys aren't just a shell website that hosts people's videos.|||所以我们现在在信息时代看到的是金字塔再次向上推移的潜力。这就是像 Udacity 这样的平台变得非常重要的地方。所以有一件事需要澄清，然后是一个评论。我们在谈论 Udacity 时，既把它当作一个学习的地方，也把它当作一个工作的地方。所以这对某些人来说可能会有点困惑。因此，谈谈 Udacity 作为工作场所可能会很好。你们不只是一个托管别人视频的空壳网站。
So maybe we can get into that a little later or whatever. But you're talking about it one way, that way, but also as a place to go and get learning. That's true. And so just people might have gotten a little totally a little mixed up there but yeah i mean i think what you guys are talking about is is interesting is that as we have as companies have trouble hiring people because the you know universities are only capable of churning out so many people and they're mostly focused on weeding out unsuccessful computer science people as opposed to in some ways making them successful that's
So maybe we can get into that a little later or whatever. But you're talking about it one way, that way, but also as a place to go and get learning. That's true. And so just people might have gotten a little totally a little mixed up there but yeah i mean i think what you guys are talking about is is interesting is that as we have as companies have trouble hiring people because the you know universities are only capable of churning out so many people and they're mostly focused on weeding out unsuccessful computer science people as opposed to in some ways making them successful that's|||所以也许我们稍后可以深入探讨这个，或者别的什么。但你从某个角度谈论它，是那个角度，但它也是一个去学习的地方。确实如此。所以大家可能会在那方面有点完全混淆了，但对，我的意思是，我认为你们谈论的内容很有趣：当公司在招聘人才时遇到困难，因为大学只能批量培养出这么多人，而且它们主要专注于淘汰不成功的计算机科学人才，而不是在某些方面让他们走向成功——
that's my personal opinion and so you know they're mostly focused on that that it may be the companies that have the pick of whoever they want it may be a difficult road may continue to be for years to come because as long as if universities are still producing enough very talented people who both had time opportunity and timing to go to university did that. They may take them preferentially, seeing it as less risk. Now, whether or not it is, you know, to be debated. But then, you know, there's always going to be those other companies that are looking,
that's my personal opinion and so you know they're mostly focused on that that it may be the companies that have the pick of whoever they want it may be a difficult road may continue to be for years to come because as long as if universities are still producing enough very talented people who both had time opportunity and timing to go to university did that. They may take them preferentially, seeing it as less risk. Now, whether or not it is, you know, to be debated. But then, you know, there's always going to be those other companies that are looking,|||这是我的个人观点——所以你知道的，它们主要专注于此。对于那些可以随心所欲挑选人才的公司来说，这可能是一条艰难的路，而且在未来几年可能依然如此，因为只要大学仍在源源不断地培养出足够多极具天赋的人，而这些人恰好有时间、机会和时机去上大学并完成了学业，公司可能就会优先录取他们，认为这样风险更小。至于事实是否如此，你知道的，还有待商榷。但是，你知道，总会有其他公司在寻找人才，
and they don't have the name recognition, maybe. It doesn't make them a bad company. It just means they're the next Google or Apple or Facebook, right? Those up and coming, when Google and Facebook were initially there, right, and now they're a big company. So there's other companies looking to become that. And so they aren't able to get the, you know, top 1% of graduates or whatever.
and they don't have the name recognition, maybe. It doesn't make them a bad company. It just means they're the next Google or Apple or Facebook, right? Those up and coming, when Google and Facebook were initially there, right, and now they're a big company. So there's other companies looking to become that. And so they aren't able to get the, you0% of graduates or whatever.|||它们可能没有那么高的品牌知名度。但这并不意味着它们是一家糟糕的公司。这只意味着它们是下一个谷歌、苹果或Facebook，对吧？那些崭露头角的公司——就像当年刚起步时的谷歌和Facebook一样，对吧，而现在它们已经是大公司了。所以还有其他公司正渴望成为那样的大公司。因此，它们无法获得顶尖 1% 的毕业生之类的人才。
And so then they have to look at other things and they're still looking for quality people and quality signals. And I think that's where we're talking about. Now it may change for the other companies as well. They may begin to accept things that they don't today. Also, you have to look at your entire career. Now it may change for the other companies as well. They may begin to accept things that they don't today. Right. Also, you have to look at your entire career. Once you're established in software engineering discipline for 10, 15 years, then the field
And so then they have to look at other things and they're still looking for quality people and quality signals. And I think that's where we're talking about. Now it may change for the other companies as well. They may begin to accept things that they don't today. Also, you have to look at your entire career. Now it may change for the other companies as well. They may begin to accept things that they don't today. Right. Also, you have to look at your entire career. Once you're established in software engineering discipline for 10, 15 years, then the field|||所以它们必须着眼于其他方面，并且它们仍在寻找优秀的人才和优质的信号。我想这正是我们正在讨论的。现在，这种情况对其他大公司也可能会改变。它们可能会开始接受那些它们今天不接受的东西。此外，你必须放眼你的整个职业生涯。现在，这种情况对其他大公司也可能会改变。它们可能会开始接受那些它们今天不接受的东西。对的。此外，你必须放眼你的整个职业生涯。一旦你在软件工程领域立足 10 年、15 年，那么这个领域
is completely equal. I mean, if someone has 15 years experience at Google, I don't know. Do you think it even takes 15? I don't know that it takes 15. Yeah, I was being extremely conservative. But if someone has five years of experience at, let's say, Google, then you're probably not looking at where they went to high school, right, or something like that. And so a lot of it is about you're getting the right experience, and then at that point you've leveled the playing field.
is completely equal. I mean, if someone has 15 years experience at Google, I don't know. Do you think it even takes 15? I don't know that it takes 15. Yeah, I was being extremely conservative. But if someone has five years of experience at, let's say, Google, then you're probably not looking at where they went to high school, right, or something like that. And so a lot of it is about you're getting the right experience, and then at that point you've leveled the playing field.|||就完全是平等的了。我的意思是，如果一个人在谷歌有 15 年的经验，我不知道。你觉得甚至需要 15 年吗？我不知道是不是需要 15 年。是的，我刚才表现得极其保守。但如果一个人在——比方说——谷歌有五年的经验，那么你大概不会去关心他上的是哪所高中，对吧，诸如此类。因此，很大程度上在于你获得了正确的经验，然后在那个时候，你已经把竞争起点拉平了。
Yeah, I think it can happen in as little as, you know, definitely five years, because if you're really go to a good company, and you're doing good work, when you go to interviews, or when I conduct interviews for people, and you ask them, like, hey, you have, like we talked about, people exaggerate their resume. So, oh, I wrote Python. Wait, I happen, no, I don't think so. But, you know, hey, I did something awesome on Python, you ask them about it, and it falls through, it makes you kind of like, now I feel bad because you've kind of not been truthful. But if you say, hey, I built a, you know, bandwidth shaping algorithm for delivery of video content or, you know, something. Right.
Yeah, I think it can happen in as little as, you know, definitely five years, because if you're really go to a good company, and you're doing good work, when you go to interviews, or when I conduct interviews for people, and you ask them, like, hey, you have, like we talked about, people exaggerate their resume. So, oh, I wrote Python. Wait, I happen, no, I don't think so. But, you know, hey, I did something awesome on Python, you ask them about it, and it falls through, it makes you kind of like, now I feel bad because you've kind of not been truthful. But if you say, hey, I built a, you know, bandwidth shaping algorithm for delivery of video content or, you know, something. Right.|||是的，我认为甚至短短五年内就能实现这一点，因为如果你真的去了一家好公司，并且做着出色的工作，当你去面试时，或者当我为主持面试时，你问他们，比如：嘿，你有——正如我们所谈到的，有人会夸大简历。所以，哦，我写过 Python。等等，我碰巧——不，我不这么认为。但是，你知道，嘿，我在 Python 上做了一件了不起的事，你问他们具体细节，结果他们答不上来，这让你觉得——现在我感觉很糟，因为你有点不诚实。但如果你说：“嘿，我为视频内容分发构建了一个带宽塑形算法”，或者诸如此类。对的。
And then you're like, whoa, tell me about that. And you can actually because you did it. You can actually talk about it. You spend years doing it. People go, oh, I can relate to this person. This person knows how to speak the language. Like they obviously know and are passionate about what they're talking about. You spend years doing it. People go, oh, I can relate to this person. This person knows how to speak the language. They obviously know and are passionate about what they're talking about.
And then you're like, whoa, tell me about that. And you can actually because you did it. You can actually talk about it. You spend years doing it. People go, oh, I can relate to this person. This person knows how to speak the language. Like they obviously know and are passionate about what they're talking about. You spend years doing it. People go, oh, I can relate to this person. This person knows how to speak the language. They obviously know and are passionate about what they're talking about.|||然后面试官会说：“哇，跟我讲讲这个。”而你真的能讲出来，因为那是你亲手做的。你确实可以侃侃而谈。你花了几年时间做这件事。大家会觉得：“哦，我能理解这个人。这个人懂得行话。他们显然知道自己在说什么，并且对此充满热情。”你花了几年时间做这件事。大家会觉得：“哦，我能理解这个人。这个人懂得行话。他们显然知道自己在说什么，并且对此充满热情。”
And then now you can get on to the other kinds of questions or interview. But you need to get to that point, right? And I think open source helps, but then I think working at a company, as you said, for some number of years and being able to say, look, I worked on this. You don't have to own it as a manager, but these were the things specifically I did. Not my team did, not the mailing list I was on did but the like here's the things I did so another kind of question along these lines is what sort of the certification process for Udacity and other sort of MOOCs and and how does this how is this
And then now you can get on to the other kinds of questions or interview. But you need to get to that point, right? And I think open source helps, but then I think working at a company, as you said, for some number of years and being able to say, look, I worked on this. You don't have to own it as a manager, but these were the things specifically I did. Not my team did, not the mailing list I was on did but the like here's the things I did so another kind of question along these lines is what sort of the certification process for Udacity and other sort of MOOCs and and how does this how is this|||然后现在你可以进入其他类型的提问或面试了。但你需要到达那个点，对吧？我认为开源有帮助，但接下来我认为在一家公司工作——正如你所说——若干年，并且能够说：“看，我参与了这个项目。你不必作为经理去拥有它，但这些正是我具体做的事情。不是我的团队做的，不是我加入的邮件列表做的，而是——这就是我所做的事情。”所以顺着这个思路的另一个问题是：Udacity 和其他 MOOC 平台的认证流程是怎样的？以及这——这与
different than a university accreditation process? As someone who doesn't know anything about either. I think there was two different things there. Well, yeah, I mean, basically, like, how do either of those two things work? Issuing a certificate to a person or accreditation to an education platform? To an education platform. Okay. Yeah.
different than a university accreditation process? As someone who doesn't know anything about either. I think there was two different things there. Well, yeah, i mean, basically, like, how do either of those two things work? Issuing a certificate to a person or accreditation to an education platform? To an education platform. Okay. Yeah.|||大学的认证流程有何不同？作为一个对两者都一无所知的人。我觉得这里面有两件不同的事。嗯，是的，我的意思是，基本上，这两者是怎么运作的？是向个人颁发证书，还是对教育平台进行认证？对教育平台的认证。好的。是的。
So how are universities... Because I'm actually interested in both. Right. How are universities accredited? How is Udacity accredited? And sort of how are these accredited how is udacity accredited and sort of how are these things similar and different right so i don't know how universities are okay apparently nobody it's i the only little bit i know is that um there's some consortium and i think they do a bunch of audits and things i have no idea i figured you i thought you were going somewhere with that no i said okay it turns out none of us know. So we all buy into the system, but none of us know how it works.
So how are universities... Because I'm actually interested in both. Right. How are universities accredited? How is Udacity accredited? And sort of how are these accredited how is udacity accredited and sort of how are these things similar and different right so i don't know how universities are okay apparently nobody it's i the only little bit i know is that um there's some consortium and i think they do a bunch of audits and things i have no idea i figured you i thought you were going somewhere with that no i said okay it turns out none of us know. So we all buy into the system, but none of us know how it works.|||那么大学是如何……因为我对这两者其实都很感兴趣。对。大学是如何获得认证的？Udacity 是如何获得认证的？以及这些认证——Udacity 是如何被认证的——这些东西有哪些相似和不同之处？所以，我不知道大学是如何……好吧，显然没人知道。我唯一知道的一点是，嗯，有什么联合会之类的，我想他们会做一堆审计之类的事情。我完全不知道。我还以为你——我以为你对这个有所了解呢。不，我说——好吧，结果我们谁也不知道。所以我们都接受了这个系统，但没有人知道它是如何运作的。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, so on the Udacity side, we offer a credential. So the idea is we build these nanodegrees with Google, Facebook, Amazon, and we're basically curating the entire sort of all the pedagogy, all the material, all the projects are geared towards what they're looking for in this particular discipline. So if we're doing the data analyst degree with Facebook, you know, we do that with data analysts from Facebook, and they're basically trying to curtail, or I'm sorry, craft a sort of pipeline of entry-level
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, so on the Udacity side, we offer a credential. So the idea is we build these nanodegrees with Google, Facebook, Amazon, and we're basically curating the entire sort of all the pedagogy, all the material, all the projects are geared towards what they're looking for in this particular discipline. So if we're doing the data analyst degree with Facebook, you know, we do that with data analysts from Facebook, and they're basically trying to curtail, or I'm sorry, craft a sort of pipeline of entry-level|||是的，完全如此。好的，在 Udacity 这边，我们提供的是一种凭证（credential）。所以我们的理念是：我们与谷歌、Facebook、亚马逊合作构建这些纳米学位（nanodegrees），我们基本上是在精心策划所有的教学法、所有的材料、所有的项目，它们都针对这些公司在这个特定学科中所寻找的人才。因此，如果我们与 Facebook 合作推出数据分析师学位，你知道的，我们是与 Facebook 的数据分析师合作完成的，他们基本上是在试图缩减——或者抱歉，是打造一种入门级
data analysts. So this is super effective, right? Because this is literally what hiring managers are looking for. And then as people come through, we find it's easy to place these people because, again, they know the curriculum was designed by us with Facebook. So we sort of take that approach to, you know, we would like to help people change their careers or get that first job. And so our idea of credentialing is go to the source. That makes sense. I mean, one sort of common complaint that can seem kind of orthogonal, but I feel now after talking to you it's kind of connected. We always kind of jest about interviews and how – so Max Howell, who invented Homebrew, which is a very popular OS X software,
data analysts. So this is super effective, right? Because this is literally what hiring managers are looking for. And then as people come through, we find it's easy to place these people because, again, they know the curriculum was designed by us with Facebook. So we sort of take that approach to, you know, we would like to help people change their careers or get that first job. And so our idea of credentialing is go to the source. That makes sense. I mean, one sort of common complaint that can seem kind of orthogonal, but I feel now after talking to you it's kind of connected. We always kind of jest about interviews and how – so Max Howell, who invented Homebrew, which is a very popular OS X software,|||数据分析师的人才管道。所以这超级有效，对吧？因为这正是招聘经理们真正在寻找的。然后随着学员学成毕业，我们发现帮这些人安排工作很容易，因为同样地，他们知道课程是由我们与 Facebook 共同设计的。所以我们采取这种方法，你知道的，我们希望帮助人们改变职业生涯或找到第一份工作。因此，我们颁发凭证的理念就是：直奔源头。这很有道理。我的意思是，有一种常见的抱怨，看起来似乎不相关（orthogonal），但在跟你聊过之后，我感觉它其实是有联系的。我们总是拿面试开玩笑，比如——发明了 Homebrew（这是一款非常流行的 OS X 软件）的马克斯·豪威尔（Max Howell），
he posted on Twitter you know you the post was a quoted post it said he was quoting as if he was I can't remember which company he applied to but it said you know you you invented homebrew but you can't invert a binary tree so get lost you know and his whole thing was you know I interviewed at this company I've all years of experience but this some academic thing from 15 years ago didn't apply, hasn't applied to me, and I didn't get it right. So I think maybe that kind of starts to build the pictures. I think a lot of academic accreditation comes from, it's just much more, has a much longer tail. In other words, the people are looking at the next 50 years or 100 years and saying, what should computer science people know 50 years from now? And the answer is yes,
he posted on Twitter you know you the post was a quoted post it said he was quoting as if he was I can't remember which company he applied to but it said you know you you invented homebrew but you can't invert a binary tree so get lost you know and his whole thing was you know I interviewed at this company I've all years of experience but this some academic thing from 15 years ago didn't apply, hasn't applied to me, and I didn't get it right. So I think maybe that kind of starts to build the pictures. I think a lot of academic accreditation comes from, it's just much more, has a much longer tail. In other words, the people are looking at the next 50 years or 100 years and saying, what should computer science people know 50 years from now? And the answer is yes,|||他在推特上发了一条引用帖，内容大概是——我记不清他申请的是哪家公司了——上面写着：“你发明了 Homebrew，但你却不会翻转二叉树，所以滚蛋吧。”你知道的，他的整件事就是：我在这家公司面试，我有这么多年的经验，但这个 15 年前的学术问题根本不适用，对我从来没用过，然后我就被刷掉了。所以我想这也许开始勾勒出全貌了。我认为许多学术认证来自——它的生命周期更长，有着更长的尾部。换句话说，人们在展望未来 50 年或 100 年，并思考：“50 年后，计算机科学专业的人应该了解什么？”而答案是，是的，
you should always know how to do sorting. And that's just a universal, right? But that puts people who get a degree in a very weird position because the industry doesn't really need that. I've never since leaving university have had to code my own sort algorithm. I would just download it. And I mean, I'm sure you're in the same boat. So there's this kind of disconnect, right? And I think by going directly to the companies and saying, what do you want, and how can we get people there? You're putting people on a direct path to something that's of value to the industry. Wait, so that's a good question, though. So if you go take data analysis, what is the actual, what were you? We have a data analyst nanodegree.
you should always know how to do sorting. And that's just a universal, right? But that puts people who get a degree in a very weird position because the industry doesn't really need that. I've never since leaving university have had to code my own sort algorithm. I would just download it. And I mean, I'm sure you're in the same boat. So there's this kind of disconnect, right? And I think by going directly to the companies and saying, what do you want, and how can we get people there? You're putting people on a direct path to something that's of value to the industry. Wait, so that's a good question, though. So if you go take data analysis, what is the actual, what were you? We have a data analyst nanodegree.|||你永远都应该知道如何编写排序算法。这是一个普遍规律，对吧？但这就把获得学位的人置于一个非常尴尬的境地，因为工业界其实并不需要这个。自从离开大学以来，我从来没有自己编写过排序算法。我都是直接下载现成的。而且我相信你们也是这样。所以这就产生了一种脱节，对吧？我认为通过直接走向企业并询问“你们想要什么，我们如何把人才培养成那样”，你是在让人们走上一条通往对行业有价值的直达路径。等等，不过这是个好问题。所以如果你去学习数据分析，实际的——你们是什么？我们有一个数据分析师纳米学位。
Okay, if I go take data analyst nanodegree, obviously probably to start I need some sort of background in programming before I start, or can I take it just, I want to do a little example walkthrough maybe. So I don't know anything. Can I just start on a degree? If you're a chemical engineer, you want to be a nano engineer. Yeah, I'm a chemical engineer, so I know math. Right. So yeah, I'd say if you're a chemical engineer, you can jump in. So we have sort of suggested prerequisites. We have a ton of free courses that can help people fill that.
好吧，如果我去参加数据分析师微学位，显然在开始之前我可能需要某种编程背景，还是我可以直接参加？我想看一个简单的流程示例。我什么都不会。我可以直接开始读这个学位吗？如果你是一名化学工程专业的学生，你想成为一名纳米工程师。是的，我是一名化学工程师，所以我懂数学。对。所以，是的，我想说如果你是化学工程师，你可以直接加入。因此，我们有提供一些建议的先修要求。我们有大量的免费课程可以帮助人们填补这些空白。
Okay. Fill those in. But it's really a question of comfort level. So you walk into DAND, and the first course is pretty basic statistics. But if you're completely uncomfortable with math, then there'd probably be some things that you'd want to do first. OK, but you've not programmed a lot.
好的。填补这些空白。但这实际上是一个熟练度的问题。当你进入微学位时，第一门课是相当基础的统计学。但是如果你对数学完全不在行，那么可能有一些事情是你需要先去做的。好的，但是你没有很多编程经验。
It would be OK. I would say we have a few senior courses that are clearly nanodegrees that are designated, like Android and senior web dev where it's definitely implicit in the title that you've already done some programming. But, and then we have, actually one of our most popular nanodegrees is intro to computer science, I'm sorry, intro to programming nanodegree and that's literally, so if you find yourself
那也没关系。我想说我们有一些高级课程，是明确指定为微学位的，比如安卓和高级网页开发，从字面上就能看出，这意味着你已经有了一些编程经验。但是，随后我们还有——实际上我们最受欢迎的微学位之一是计算机科学导论——抱歉，是编程导论微学位，而这可以说是——如果你发现自己在
in another nanodegree having trouble with the sort of assumption of programming experience and just go to intro to programming and that's literally regardless of where you really want to go ios or java android whatever um this gets you up to speed on sort of the basics of programming um but again it's not a strong computer science focus necessarily so the idea is to get you to be productive and so if you came from okay i'm a chemical engineer. I went through the nanodegree. You know, it's good. Facebook presumably came to you or you went to them and said, like, hey, let's create this together.
另一个微学位中遇到了编程经验假设带来的困难，那就去学编程导论。这基本上是针对不管你想去哪个方向——iOS、Java、安卓还是其他什么——这个课程能让你快速掌握编程基础。不过话说回来，它不一定专注于强大的计算机科学理论。所以这个想法是让你能够快速上手并产出成果。如果你来自——好吧，我是一个化学工程师。我学完了微学位。你知道，这挺好的。Facebook可能找到了你，或者你去找他们，说，嘿，我们一起来创建这个吧。
So they have some, like, we like what's in here. We looked at the syllabus. We've maybe taken the classes, whatever, you know, sign off on it. But then, you know, taking that and making it a job at Facebook, you at Facebook is probably a helpful thing, right? But is that sufficient? Because I would imagine Facebook wants to know, hey, if we want to switch you from, I don't know, maybe they have a specific data analyst position that isn't also expected to do programming that does other stuff.
所以他们会有一些——比如，我们喜欢这里面的内容。我们看过了教学大纲。我们可能上过这些课，诸如此类，你知道的，他们认可了。但是随后，你知道，拿着这个并在Facebook找到一份工作，在Facebook工作可能是一件有帮助的事情，对吧？但这就足够了吗？因为我想象Facebook会想知道，嘿，如果我们想把你从——我不知道，也许他们有一个特定的数据分析师职位，同时不需要进行编程，而是做其他事情。
But hey, we want that background. Would it be, look, we want a nanodegree in that and something else? Or do you think a nanodegree in that and, hey hey you can start becoming a data analyst and learn the rest on the job do you see where i'm kind of well i mean i i i think with entry-level positions there's always that component of you you know as a hiring manager you hardly ever get everything i keep switching hats here and like from hiring uh talking about audacity but you know as a hiring manager i hardly ever get everything I want in any
但是嘿，我们想要这个背景。会是这样吗——看，我们需要那个微学位再加上点别的？还是你认为只要有那个微学位，然后，嘿，嘿，你就可以开始当数据分析师，其余的在工作中学习？你明白我的意思吗？——嗯，我的意思是，我认为对于入门级职位，总是会有那种成分——你知道，作为一个招聘经理，你几乎永远无法得到所有东西——我一直在换角色，从招聘——谈论Udacity，但你知道，作为一个招聘经理，我在任何一个
hire and there's always an on the job component and often times they bring things
录用人选中几乎永远无法得到我想要的所有东西，
that you didn't expect which are awesome but no absolutely people that come out of
并且总会有边工作边学习的部分，而且通常他们会带来
the data analyst degree get data analyst jobs I guess if they want to move into
你意想不到的东西，这非常棒。但是，不，绝对的，从数据分析微学位毕业的人得到了数据分析师的工作。我想如果他们想调到
another role at that company then maybe they come back and take another data analyst degree which Okay. You know, whether, I guess if they want to move into another role at that company, then maybe they come back and take another nanonavigate. Sure, sure. Which would be awesome. Cool. That makes sense.
该公司的其他职位，那么也许他们会回来再修另一个数据分析微学位，好吧。你知道，不管——我想如果他们想调到该公司的其他职位，那么也许他们会回来再修另一个微学位。当然，当然。那太棒了。酷。这讲得通。
So, tell us a little bit, you know, more specific about Udacity. Kind of tell us sort of where did the idea come from? What was sort of day one at Udacity like from, you know, talking to people and things like that who, you know who were there at conception? What's sort of the history like, the sort of ramp up, and where is sort of Udacity now? Yeah, so in 2011, Sebastian Thrun, our founder, he was a professor in AI at Stanford.
那么，给我们讲讲，你知道的，更多关于Udacity的细节。跟我们讲讲这个想法是怎么来的？从那些在创立之初就在那里的人们的角度来看，Udacity的第一天是什么样的？历史是怎样的，发展速度如何，Udacity现在又在哪里？是的，所以在2011年，我们的创始人塞巴斯蒂安·特伦（Sebastian Thrun），他是斯坦福大学的人工智能教授。
And I'm not really sure what predicated this, but he decided to make it available, the course, that semester, available to everyone in the world. And this was real time. And they were doing the full experience just for anybody that wanted to attend. And I don't remember the exact numbers. I want to say it was like 60,000 students. Wow.
我其实不太确定是什么促成了这一点，但他决定把那学期的课程对全世界所有人开放。这是实时的。他们为任何想参加的人提供完整的体验。我不记得具体数字了。我想大概是6万名学生。哇。
That's a lot. I'm being told it was over 100,000 students oh wow signed up uh and um and it was taking that one class yeah exactly and so and they're they're grading everything and it's it's insane doesn't scale um right but what he was shocked by and what you know the sort of um nucleus of udacity was that he had to, when they got done and they ranked everybody, the first Stanford student was like 47. And so the first 46 people in the class were remote. And he's like, we, and so the idea was, how do we scale this? And so that is the sort of inception of Udacity.
那很多。有人告诉我那是超过10万名学生。哦，哇，注册了。呃，而且——而且他们只是在上那一门课。对，没错。所以——而且他们在给所有东西评分，这太疯狂了，无法扩展，对吧？但他感到震惊的是——Udacity的核心所在——是当他们完成课程并给每个人排名时，第一个斯坦福学生排在大概第47位。因此，班上前46名都在远程。他说，我们——所以当时的想法是，我们如何将其规模化？这就是Udacity创立的起点。
And since then, you know, and it was one of the first companies, well, that was probably the first MOOC that was real-time. And then, you know, sort of experimenting with those massive, massive open online course models at the beginning. And over time, iterating to this, you know, Sebastian likes to say, and I agree with it, I think it's true, is that the fundamental, and I know a lot of people would disagree, but the fundamental value proposition of an education is a job. And so we, over time, evolved to that. And those are some of the most rewarding things for us individually and as a company, as a business, is seeing the people who we help
从那时起，你知道，它是最早的公司之一——好吧，那可能是第一个实时的MOOC。然后，你知道，在开始时尝试那些大规模开放在线课程的模型。随着时间的推移，迭代到这个——你知道，塞巴斯蒂安喜欢说，我也赞同，我认为这是真的，那就是教育的基本——我知道很多人会不同意，但教育的基本价值主张是一份工作。所以我们随着时间推移演变成了这样。对于我们个人、公司以及业务而言，看到那些我们帮助
reach these goals. You know, they're in one job, they're dreaming of, you know, getting over it, and then it happens through this process. And, you know, to your point about earlier we were talking about they finish the data analyst nanodegree and then they get a job at Facebook. But actually, we have a whole careers group that helps people that does resume reviews, GitHub reviews, LinkedIn reviews. Engineers on my team do mock interviews, so we give them like the full Silicon Valley interview experience. But actually the really cool thing about that is
达到这些目标的人，是最有回报的事情之一。你知道，他们在一份工作中，梦想着超越现状，然后这一切通过这个过程发生了。而且，你知道，就像我们之前讨论的那样，他们完成了数据分析微学位，然后在Facebook找到了一份工作。但实际上，我们有一个专门的职业发展团队，帮助人们进行简历审查、GitHub审查、LinkedIn审查。我团队中的工程师会进行模拟面试，所以我们为他们提供完整的硅谷面试体验。但实际上，关于这一点非常酷的一点是，
what you don't normally get to do when you interview somebody. Tell them how they did? Exactly. So you do a 45-minute interview, and then you talk to them for 45 minutes and kind of, you know, give them feedback. Let them know what talk to them for 45 minutes and kind of you know give them feedback let them know what they could do better but also kind of pump them up I have a friend who stopped interviewing because wait doing interviews or going on interviews no he stopped conducting
这是你面试别人时通常做不到的。告诉他们表现如何？ exactement。没错。所以你进行45分钟的面试，然后和他们交谈45分钟，给出反馈。让他们知道——和他们交谈45分钟，给他们反馈，让他们知道
because so many times people felt like they were doing good and they weren't or vice versa and he couldn't give the feedback back to them and it's sort of like leaves this hole so we should clarify that for because not everybody may know how that works because it was kind of interesting to me because when I got my first job it was a non-technical interview so they just ask you like tell us about a time where you didn't like
他们可以做得更好的地方，同时也鼓励鼓励他们。我有个朋友不再参与面试了，因为——等等，是进行面试还是去参加面试？不，他不再担任面试官了，
someone and had to work with them and yeah so anyway so that's a little bit different but for technical interviews it when you go to job training at a job or when you go on an interview you know what you should expect is that the interview person giving the interview will not tell you anything so you'll they'll say hey you know I have a problem I want you to solve this problem you know go to the whiteboard write it down or over the phone type it into some online sharing thing and then they will sit there quietly and maybe ask a question or two, tell you the next step. But they won't tell you, oh, that's right. Or, wow, that's good. Or, ooh, yeah, you know.
因为很多时候人们觉得自己表现很好，但实际上并没有，反之亦然，而他又无法把反馈告诉他们，这就像留下了一个空白。所以我们应该为听众澄清这一点，因为不是每个人都知道这是怎么运作的，这对我来说挺有趣的，因为当我得到第一份工作时，这是一场非技术面试，他们只是问你，比如，告诉我们一次你讨厌某个人却不得不和他共事经历，对。所以无论如何，这有点不同。但对于技术面试来说，当你去公司的职业培训或者参加面试时，你应该期望的是：进行面试的人不会告诉你任何事情。所以他们会说，嘿，你知道，我有一个问题，我想让你解决这个问题，去白板前写下来，或者在电话里把它打到某个在线共享的东西上。然后他们会静静地坐在那里，也许问一两个问题，告诉你下一步。但他们不会告诉你，哦，那对了。或者，哇，那很好。或者，哦，是的，你知道的。
There's nothing. Nothing. You just stare. So sometimes I've been in ones where people just stare at their laptop the whole time. There's no feedback. And that's actually by training. They tell you do not give feedback. say for you know potential lawsuit reasons or whatever you know and that may be but even even lawsuit notwithstanding you don't want i mean what you don't want is the person goes through five interviews all five people tell them they're great and they don't get the job yeah exactly yeah just and also you don't want to become violent like yeah i'm sure there's lots and lots and lots of reasons he gets hard interviews apparently i don't want to take your interview. No, no, no, no.
什么都没有。什么都没有。你只能干瞪眼。所以有时我遇到过这种面试，面试官全程只是盯着他们的笔记本电脑。没有任何反馈。这其实是经过培训的。他们被告知绝对不要给出反馈。为了潜在的诉讼原因或其他什么，你知道，这也许是原因之一。但即使撇开诉讼不谈，你也不希望——我的意思是，你不希望的是这个人经历了五场面试，所有五个人都告诉他他很棒，结果他却没有得到这份工作。是的，确实如此，就是这样。而且你也不想变得情绪激动甚至暴力，比如——是的，我确信有非常非常非常多的原因。他遇到了艰难的面试，显然我不想参加你的面试。不，不，不，不。
But, yeah, so people's just opinion of themselves are way higher than to your point, right? People think they're doing great. But, so, yeah, that's great, right? That, you know, having someone tell you at the end, hey, you did this at this point or you did that at that point or you forgot to do this is, like, really helpful. Because it's very nerve-wracking to essentially be talking to a wall that you feel is judging you so it's not even they may think wow this is the best person i've ever seen but they'll probably get that poker face and not tell you anything what's what's the connection between the nano degree and the sort of job training job preparation is there a job preparation nano degree or is that come along with all the other
但是，是的，所以人们对自己的评价比——正如你所说的那样——要高得多，对吧？人们觉得自己做得很好。但是，是的，这很好，对吧？在最后有人告诉你，嘿，你在这一点上做了这个，或者你在那一点上做了那个，或者你忘了做这个，这真的很有帮助。因为基本上是对着一个你觉得在评判你的墙说话，会让人感到非常紧张。所以甚至都不是因为他们可能会想：哇，这是我见过最棒的人。他们很可能会保持扑克脸，什么都不告诉你。微学位与这种职业培训、职业准备之间有什么联系？有没有一种职业准备微学位，还是说它伴随着所有其他学位一起提供？
degrees so the career services come along with the nanodegree guys there is an additional thing called career advisor and we've launched something recently that we're super excited about which is a job guarantee so I saw the email on this yeah so it's it's it's an additional hundred dollars a month while you're enrolled but then we guarantee to find you a job in six months or we just pay back your entire tuition so but yeah on the the career services thing is really interesting like all the engineers love doing this um because you do do the poker face thing for the first 45 minutes because i think all of us remember our
职业服务是随微学位一起附赠的。还有一个额外的服务叫做职业顾问，我们最近推出了一个让我们超级兴奋的新功能，那就是就业保证。我看到这封电子邮件了。是的，所以——这是一个额外的服务，在注册期间每月100美元，但我们保证在六个月内为你找到工作，否则我们退还你的全部学费。所以，关于职业服务的部分真的很有趣，所有的工程师都很喜欢做这个，因为在前45分钟里你确实得保持扑克脸，因为我认为我们所有人都记得我们
first maybe maybe not first maybe first 10 15 you know interviews throughout over your the course of your career and they're stressful i mean they're incredibly stressful they're stressful for both people to be fair you may not know that but if you get if you're getting someone who's giving their first interview they're probably to be and it sounds silly how could this be but i tell you the first time you give an interview to someone and you're like oh i think this person's like twice as qualified as i am it's very intimidating it is right and you keep your poker face so you have an upper hand but you know you feel very nervous or like you're you're Or like the question that's supposed to take 20 minutes of the interview, and they're just like... In two minutes.
第一次——也许吧，也许不是第一次，也许是职业生涯前10到15场面试——这些面试都很有压力。我的意思是，它们压力极大。公平地说，对双方来说都压力很大。你可能不知道，但如果你面对的是一个正在进行人生第一次面试的面试官，他们可能——这听起来很傻，怎么会这样？但我告诉你，当你第一次面试别人时，你会想：哦，我觉得这个人比我有资格得多。这非常吓人。确实如此，对吧？你必须保持扑克脸来占据上风，但你知道，你内心其实非常紧张，或者说——或者就像本该花20分钟的面试问题，他们只要两分钟就——
You're like, oh, no! What was that second question? Exactly. But yeah. Yeah, totally. So yeah, so when you're doing a nano degree, the Udacity is trying to provide more than just, hey, take this course, take this, take this course. They're trying to help you grow, right? They're trying to create you a career path
你就想，哦，不！第二个问题是什么来着？完全正确。但是，是的。完全如此。所以，是的，当你攻读微学位时，Udacity试图提供的不仅仅是，嘿，参加这门课，参加那门课，参加这门课。他们试图帮助你成长，对吧？如果你正在寻找这样的发展，他们正试图为你开辟一条职业道路。
if that's what you're looking for. Presumably some people may not be looking for that. They're just learning. Actually, that's a good question. So if someone is just a pure academic, maybe they have no interest in a software engineering job. Maybe they're perfectly happy being a lawyer, but they just want to learn just in a very sort of like high level academic setting,
据推测，有些人可能并不是在寻找这个。他们只是在学习。事实上，这是一个好问题。如果有人只是一个纯粹的学术爱好者，也许他对软件工程工作完全没有兴趣。也许他当律师当得非常开心，但他只是想在一个非常高水平的学术环境中学习计算机科学、或者任何东西、经济学之类的。有没有这样的课程？有没有这样一种——我的意思是，因为这在目标方面与微学位有点不同，对吧？那么你们是如何平衡这一点的呢？所以我们有——从历史上看，我们有一些心理学课程。我想还有一些经济学课程。至于微学位，我们的目标完全是让人们在科技行业找到工作。所以微学位几乎完全专注于此。我们有一个科技创业微学位，它更侧重于创业和经营企业。
computer science or anything, economics or something. Are there those courses? Is there a sort of, I mean, because that's a little different than a nano degree in terms of sort of the goals, right? So how do you sort of balance that? So we have, you know, historically we have some psychology courses. I think there's some econ courses. With nano degrees, it's just been totally let's get people jobs in tech. So nano degrees are almost exclusively focused on that. We have a tech entrepreneur nano degree, which is more focused on sort of starting a business, running a business.
但是对于学术领域的学科——更学术的学科，我想我们有这些免费课程，但这并不是我们的核心业务。这不是我们——你知道，我们的宏愿不是帮人找到经济学家的工作。你不会去讲这个。所以现在你们关注的，听起来
But for the academic the more academic subjects I guess we have these free courses but it's not really our main business. It's not what we you know we don't aspire to get people jobs as economists. You're not going to go over that. So now you're focused on, it sounds like
主要是技术，甚至计算机科学是大头。但是，你们认为这会过渡到其他领域吗？如果突然之间数学工厂开始涌现，你需要人们来制造数学零件，那么你们也可以转型，对吧？我的意思是，我们已经变得相当——所以我们与谷歌合作开发的机器学习微学位和深度学习课程，
mostly technology or even computer science as a big focus. But then, do you see that transitioning to other areas? If all of a sudden the math factories start popping up and you need people to make widgets of math, then you could pivot, right? I mean, we've gotten pretty, so the machine learning nanodegree and the deep learning course that we did with Google,
我的意思是，那变得越来越实用。我觉得我的工作需要了解这些，你知道的。所以，这是合理的。我们在那里突破了界限。历史上，我们的第一门课程也是人工智能。我们某种程度上坚持了这一点。这说得通。但是不，对我们来说，这一切都是为了——
I mean, that's getting more and more practical. I feel like I need to know it, you know, for my job. And so, but that's fair. We push the boundaries there. We've been doing, also, historically, our first course was AI. We kind of stick to that. Makes sense. But no, really for us, it's all about,
我们对帮人找到工作的这个使命充满热情。酷。所以我觉得那里还有些内容。那么对于那些只是想旁听的人来说——比如著名的审理太阳微系统公司诉谷歌侵犯Java API版权案的法官就曾说过，嗯，嘿，这非常微妙。我应该去学编程。他在法庭上承认他去——
we're passionate about this mission of getting people jobs. Cool. So I think there was still something there. So for people who are just looking to audit, so like famously the judge ruling over Sun versus Google over Java APIs is like, well, hey, this is super subtle. Like I should go learn programming. And he admitted from the bench that he had gone and, you know,
读了关于编程的书。还记得他说的话吗？基本上，他自学了编程。至于达到了什么程度，我不确定。你知道，他是一位法官。他可能真的很忙。但是，你知道，如果他想来上课，对吧——那里有没有一种选项，类似于，嘿，
read about programming and read a book. Remember what he said? Basically, he taught himself programming. Now, to what degree, I'm not sure. You know, he's a judge. He's probably really busy. But, you know, if he wanted to come take, right, like is there an option there to kind of like, hey,
我只是旁听几门课？它的水平是这样的吗？基于他的需求，他能很容易地识别出哪些课该上、哪些课不该上吗？没错，这是我们模式的一个重要部分。所以这是一个免费增值（freemium）模式。我们所有的课程材料都是免费提供的。所以如果你的全部目的只是观看视频和查阅资料，任何人都可以做到这一点。你只需注册，然后开始就行了。微学位更多的是关于它周边的服务。所以项目
I'm just auditing a couple courses. Is it at that level? Is it easy for him to identify here's some things to take versus not take because of what I'm looking for? Right, this is an important part of our model. So it's a freemium, you know, model. All of our course material is available for free. So if all you want to do is, you know, watch the videos and look at the material, anybody can do that. You just sign up, do it. The NetAgre is more about the services around it. So the project
代码审查，一对一辅导。所以我想这取决于你是否能从中获益。你知道，如果你能从一对一导师那里获得价值，即使你不需要找工作，微学位可能仍然适合你。如果你能从代码审查过程中受益，那仍然会很棒。所以，就是这样。
code reviews, the one-on-one mentoring. So I guess it depends on whether you learn about it. You know, if you would get value out of a one-on-one mentor, even if you didn't need a job, then the Nanodegree probably is still for you. If you could benefit out of that code review process, that would still be great. But, so.
我认为这实际上是一个很好的区别。我绝不会要求你说这个领域其他人的坏话，但我的意思是，我想我去过其他一些平台，哦，这里有一门关于某某的课程。它确实如此。他们只是想为视频收费。这就是他们售卖的东西。我觉得你刚才说的很有意思，你们不是在卖视频。你们不是在卖学习。
And I think that's actually a great distinction. I would never ask you to talk bad about other people in this space, but I mean, I think I've been on other places like, oh, here is a course about blah. And it really is. They want to just charge you for the videos. Like that's the thing they're selling. And I think that's interesting what you said, that you guys aren't trying to sell videos. You're not trying to sell learning.
人们可以自己学习。你们想要传递知识。你们想要帮助人们。但是，我的意思是，让人花一个半小时在电话那头做45分钟面试和45分钟反馈是需要成本的。进行代码审查和同行评审也是需要成本的。这些人必须——按理说，他们必须是该领域的从业者，否则就没什么意义，因此它是有成本的，对吧？所以有趣的是，这是你们正在尝试做的事情——我认为这是一个非常——这真的是在我听到你这么说之前我没有真正理解的事情。是的，我们基本上是为服务收费的。
People can learn. You want the knowledge. You want to help people. But I mean, it costs money to have someone give down the phone for 40 hour and a half doing 45 minutes of an interview and 45 minutes feedback. It costs money to have code review and peer review. Those people have to be, by necessity, they could be in the field, right, or else it's kind of meaningless and so therefore it's gonna cost, right? And so it's interesting that that's the thing you're trying, I think that's a very, like that's something I didn't really understand, I guess, prior to you saying this. Yeah, we basically charge for the services, essentially.
是的，在此之前我也一直以为这些钱只是为了买个证书。我之前真的没有意识到免费层和付费层之间有不同的服务。所以这其实非常合理。我的意思是，是这些服务带来了凭证。没错，但你两者都能得到。你不是在花钱买一张纸。没错，但你两者都能得到。是的。嗯，你不是在花钱买一张纸。没错，没错。
Yeah, I'd also thought up until now that the money was just sort of for the certificate. I hadn't really understood that there were different services for the premium versus the free tier. And so that actually makes a ton of sense. And I mean, it's the services that lead to the credential. Right, but you get both. But you're not paying for a piece of sense. And I mean, it's the services that lead to the credential. Right, but you get both. Yeah. Well, you're not paying for a piece of paper. Right, right.
我想在某种程度上，人们会说在大学里你是在花钱买一张纸。但那并不是真的。我的意思是，在大学里，嗯，你可能会批评有些课确实如此，但他们通常不会只是让你坐那儿看一整天视频。比如有给你作业评分的助教。有教授你可以去他们的办公室答疑时间，他们会以互动的方式在理论上进行讲授。互动的部分可能取决于你的大学。但理论上，你买的是那个，对吧？你为之付出了代价。除了拿到一张纸，他们还得有人在那里。
And I guess to some extent, people say that at university, you're paying for a piece of paper. But that's not really true. I mean, university, well, you may criticize in some classes they do, but they don't typically just sit you down and show you a video for the entire time. Like there's TAs who grade your paper. There's professors who you can go to their office hours and they interactively give the lecture theoretically. The interactivity part may depend on your university. But in theory, you're paying for that, right? You're paying for it. In addition to getting a piece of paper, but they have to have people there.
这不可能是完全自动化的。它无法以同样的方式扩展。正是如此。我觉得这其实有两点——这也是让教育变得如此困难的原因之一——一项服务有太多的目标，对吧？我的意思是——一方面，它是通往学术界的钥匙。所以如果你想写研究论文，你必须去上大学，所以有这方面的原因，就像有些如果你想打开一扇门，一扇非常特定的门，只有一种方法能打开那扇门。但如果你想写某种非常特定的学术论文，比如同行评审的、在期刊上发表的学术论文，那还有其他所有。好吧，公平地说，没有那个标签你也可以发表同样高质量的论文。哦，那是对的。
It's not like they can just make that autonomous. It can't scale in the same way. That's right. I feel like there's actually two so this is one thing that makes education so difficult is that there's so many goals from one service right i mean so one is it's a key to academia so if you want to write research papers you have to go to college and so there's there's that part of it where like some if you want a certain door a very specific door to open there's only one way to open that door but there's all if you want to write a very specific kind of academic paper, like peer-reviewed, journal-published academic paper. Okay, just to be fair, I mean, you could just publish an equal quality paper without that tag. Oh, that's right.
好的。对。但是，嗯……我稍微把你打断了一下。好吧，为了不偏离主题太远，很多学术论文都是经过同行评审的。所以尽管这是双盲同行评审，它也变得有点像一个小圈子。你必须成为这个小圈子的一部分才能发表论文。好吧。
Okay. Right. But, well... I distracted you a little. Well, not to go on too much of a tangent, but a lot of academic papers are peer-reviewed. And so even though it's a double-blind peer review, it becomes sort of a clique. You have to be part of the clique to get the paper published. Okay.
无论如何，这是一个目标。但那是少数人的目标，没多少人。这就像发生了一种逆指数现象。基本上，你在大学里的每一年，都有半数的人退学。从第一年、大一，一直到博士最后一年，都是这样。
Anyway, but that's one goal. But then that's the minority of people, not many people. Like there's this inverse exponential thing that goes on. Basically, every year you're in college, half the people drop out. And this goes from first year, freshman year, all the way to last year of PhD.
所以到了最后其实没剩下几个人。所以对于其他人来说，你真正想要的是改变你的分布。换句话说，如果我要从帽子里随机抽出一个有计算机科学学位的人。分院帽？就像哈利·波特那样，是的。如果我要随机挑选一个有计算机科学学位的人和一个没有计算机科学学位的人，
And so there's really nobody left at the end. So for everybody else, you're really wanting to change your distribution. So in other words, if I was to pick a person out of a hat who has a CS degree. A sorting hat? Like, yeah, like Harry Potter, yeah. If I was to just randomly pick a person who has a CS degree and randomly pick a person who doesn't,
那么第一个分布更有可能倾向于在工作中表现更好的人。所以我认为通过提供这些服务，你可以做到——不仅是帮助候选人，你还在向公司提供担保。比方说，如果我录用了一个Udacity微集学位毕业生，那么我招进来的这个人，我有一定程度的信心他能胜任这个角色。我认为这是双向的。我的意思是，这在我们身上已经发挥到了极致。我们最近与印度的Flipkart达成了协议，Flipkart是印度的亚马逊，他们实际上与我们达成了一项协议，
then the first distribution hopefully skews more towards someone who's going to do better in the job. And so I think that by providing sort of these services, you can provide, not only is it helping the candidates, but you're providing guarantees to the companies. Let's say, if I'm going to draw a Udacity nano graduate, then I'm going to draw someone who I know will fit the role with some amount of confidence. I think it works both ways. I mean, that's gone to an extreme with us. We just recently did a deal with Flipkart in India, the Amazon of India, and they actually did a deal with us
要在印度雇用微学位毕业生，未曾谋面，无需面试。哇，哇！所以这有点像我们终极目标的实现，能够……除了这给你们带来了巨大的责任。确实如此。现在你们必须防范欺诈之类的事情，对吧？比如如果有人抄袭别人的。
to hire nanodegree grads in India, sight unseen, no interview. Wow, wow. So it's kind of like the manifestation of our ultimate goal to just be able to... Except that pushes a big responsibility on you guys. It does. Now you've got to, you know, protect against things like fraud, right? So if someone's copying someone else.
确实。我不是故意要谈这个，对吧？但是我的意思是，如果你要把它当作——嘿，这些人要雇用你。这里面有一种信任。如果你滥用了这一点，你就会失去它，遭到痛击并得到糟糕的媒体报道。其实我想的是别的事。我更多地是在想文化契合度之类的事情。这很难——比如你希望有机会去说，
That's true. I don't mean to talk about it, right? But I mean, if you're going to have that as like, hey, these people are going to hire you. There's a trust there. If you abuse that, you'll lose it and get slammed and get bad press. I was actually thinking something different. I was thinking more just like culture fit and things like that. It's hard to sort of, like you want to be given the chance to say,
是的，这个人拥有所有的技能，但他们并不适合Flipkart。是的，但这个人最终可能会得到这份工作，却不喜欢它，并在一段时间后转型去做别的。这倒也是。或者他们可以不接受这个Offer，对吧？没错，确实如此。所以当然，还有其他的事情，也许他们仍然会进行面试，无论如何——但是“未曾谋面”的招聘，对吧？像那样的话，你们必须防范——如何做到这一点——这也是我通常有的另一个问题，
yes, this person has all the skills, but they don't fit the flip part. Yeah, but I mean the person could ultimately get the job and not like it and transition to something else after a period of time. That's true. Or they don't have to accept presumably the offer, right? Right, that's true. So sure, there's other things and maybe they still conduct yeah anyways whatever but slight unseen hiring right like then you guys have to protect against like how do and this goes another question i have in general which
就是你怎么确保人们就是他们所说的那个人，做着他们所说的事情，同时又提供与其他人的互动？比如在大学里，你做小组项目，我认为大学里这也是个问题，当然是的。所以我有点把这两者结合起来——这是真的。怎么确保——没有面对面的部分，对吧？所以——你们怎么确保这个人就是他们所说的那个人，然后你们又如何在同龄人之间提供这种人与人之间的互动？我们在你毕业时使用身份认证服务，至于诈骗或作弊，这和其他任何机构的情况都一样。
is you know how do you make sure the people are the people they say they are and doing the things they say they're doing but then also providing the interaction with other people so like you know in college you do group projects and i think college it's also a problem like sure it is so I kind of those two things that's true how do there's no in-person part right so like I how do you make sure the person is who they say they are and then how do you provide that person-to-person interaction among peers so we use an identity certification service when you graduate and as far as you know fraud or cheating is the same as it would be in any institution.
你走在它前面，发现新东西。当然，不要说任何具体的内容。而那个算法，不。我们所做的，让它实现规模化是一个有趣的工程挑战。但是，是的，不，你绝对是对的。这是我们保持警惕的事情，因为如果这些事情发生了，不仅是对Flipkart，而且总的来说，这个凭证就不名一文了。而且，你知道，它是有价值的，我们将确保它是有价值的。所以我们在这上面非常努力地工作。
You get ahead of it, find something new. Sure, don't say anything specific. And the algorithm, no. What we do, making that scale is a fun technical challenge. But yeah, no, you're absolutely right. And it's something that we're vigilant about because if those things happen, not just with Flipkart, but in general, the credential is not worth anything. And, you know, it is worth something, and we're going to make sure it's worth something. So we work really hard on that.
而且，再次强调，因为人们不在同一个地方，你知道，互动必然会有所不同。但你们是怎么处理这一点的？它们其实没那么相关。不，关于这一点，我更多地认为那是一种——那有助于人们学习，这不是——不是作为验证或欺诈防范，对吧，对吧，不，不。但——这是我们从产品角度做了很多工作的一个领域，我们只是想让它尽可能像在教室里一样。所以我们把人们作为一个同届群体（cohort）组织起来，当他们加入时，
And then, again, because people aren't in a place, you know, the interaction will necessarily be different. But how do you kind of handle that? They weren't really that related. No, so on that, I think of that more is a that helps people learn that's uh not not so much as a validation or fraud yeah yeah yeah no no but yeah the the this is something that we work on a lot from a product perspective where we just want to make it as much like being in a classroom as possible so we cohort people as they join So they see those same people throughout their... Oh, that's cool.
这样他们在整个过程中都能看到同样的人……哦，太酷了。你们有和那些人相同的截止日期。我们尝试了许多实时聊天、类似学习小组的东西，这些都显示出巨大的潜力，我们会继续关注这一点。我们还尽可能地在拥有最多学生的不同的城市举办面对面的活动。我们会举办这种面对面的黑客马拉松或只是
You have the same deadlines as those folks. And we've experimented with a lot of sort of real-time chat, sort of study group-type things, and those have shown tremendous promise, and we'll keep looking at that. We also, as often as we can, we host sort of in-person in different cities where we have the most students. We'll host these sort of in-person hackathons or just
聚会。我们发现，我的意思是，这些人的参与度非常巨大。我的意思是，我们现在的参与度已经很好了，但那些真正感觉自己是团队一部分的人——这就是大学的氛围，对吧？他们在留存率方面、在按原定时间完成项目方面，表现都要好得多。我的意思是，我应该指出，你可以按照自己的节奏学习。这些截止日期某种程度上只是为了帮助激励人们。但是，你知道，从来没有人因为错过了截止日期之类的事情而被淘汰出局。
meetups. And we found that, I mean, the engagement with those folks is just huge. I mean, we have good engagement as it is, but the folks that actually feel like they're part of a group, and it's, you know, it's the college thing, right? They just, they do much better in terms of retention, in terms of, you know, getting projects done on the original timeline. I mean, I should point out that you can work at your own pace. These deadlines are sort of just to help motivate people. But then, you know, nobody ever fails out because they, you know, missed a deadline or something like that.
但我认为杰森（Jason）说的是真的。我的意思是，你们必然会遭遇流失率，对吧？有些人生了开始的念头却没能坚持到最后。然后，比如拥有一个团队来——你是否发现人们报告说这些团队有助于他们保持动力，去——你知道的，如果你没有任何日程表，如果我只是——我参加过好几个慕课（MOOC），我想我一个都没完成，因为我是个糟糕的人。确实如此。我学到一半，你知道，参加了四个不同的课程。
But I think what Jason says is true. I mean, you guys must suffer attrition, right? People who start something and don't finish. And then, like, having a group to kind of, do you find that people are reporting that the groups help them to stay motivated to like, you know, if you have no schedule, if I'm just like, I've taken a couple of moves and I don't think I finished any because I'm a terrible person. That's true. I'm halfway through, you know, four different.
是的。这部分是因为我并不是为了找工作。我只是在学习一些额外的知识。我并不是在寻找证书，因为在我人生的这个阶段，我不追求这个。嗯，并不是说我永远不会，但是，嗯，随着我们继续，对吧——我退学了，诸如此类。当你发现时，人们是否报告说在这些小组中，他们获得了保持课程进度的动力，并坚持一个——你知道的，即使它是自律的——截止日期？
Yeah. So that's partly because like I'm not seeking to get a job. I'm just picking up some extra learning. I'm not trying to look for a certification because at this point in my life, I'm not seeking it. Um, not that I won't ever, but, um, so as we move on, right, like I drop out, whatever, and when you find, do people report that in these groups, they get, you know, motivation to keep the course and like stay on a, you know, deadline, even if it's, you know, self-imposed.
嗯，所以我们做了一堆事情来帮助解决这个问题。所以——我的意思是，是的，我们有流失率，就像任何人一样。人们投入更多一点是因为他们在付费。我们还——如果你在头12个月内完成了微学位，我们会把一半的学费退给你——我不知道这一点，好吧。嗯，这很难做到吗？我的意思是，我只是——不，你知道，我不了解——一个人每周需要花多少个小时才能在一年内完成一个微学位？我的意思是，这是一个具体的问题。这是一个好问题，但它的差异很大，因为人们在做这个时，你知道，人们在做微学位的同时还在做他们的全职工作或者还在上学。他们有不同的背景。
Well, so we've done a bunch of stuff to help with that um so i mean yeah we have attrition like any people are a little more invested because they're paying um we also if you if you finish your nanodegree in the first and within 12 months we give you half your tuition back um i didn't know that okay um and is that hard to do i mean i just like no you know i don't know like how many hours like how many hours a week would it take a person to finish a nanodegree in a year? I mean, that's all the specific question, but. It's a good one, but it varies a lot because people are doing this, you know, people do nanodegrees while they're at their current job or while they're going to school. They have different backgrounds.
对。所以，我的意思是，所有微学位的平均时间大约是六个月。哦，好吧。而且——但我们在两端都看到了极端情况。你知道，我们见过有人在三个月内完成的。但是如果你有合理的——你知道，虽然没有保证，但如果你有合理的动力，并且真的在努力推进，在一年内完成并不是一项不可能完成的任务。哦，不，一点也不。所以，你知道，我最近雇用了我们的一位毕业生，他在大约七个月的时间里完成了我们的三个微学位。哇。
Right. And so, I mean, the average is about six months across all nanodegrees. Oh, okay. And, but we've seen extremes on both ends. You know, we've seen people finish them in three months. But if you're reasonably, you know, there's no promise, but if you're reasonably motivated and you're really trying to drive at it, getting through in a year isn't an impossible task. Oh, no, not at all. So, you know, I recently hired one of our graduates that finished three of our nanodegrees in the course of about seven months. Wow.
这算是一种自举吗？我培訓了这家伙，然后他来为我工作。这很有趣。当我在这里面试时，我曾问：你们自己用自己的产品吗（dog food）？你们会在工程团队中雇用你们的毕业生吗？我很高兴答案是肯定的。但是，是的，他一直很棒。所以，我的意思是，这些极具动力的人
Is that some kind of bootstrap? I trained this guy, and then he came and worked for me. It's funny. When I interviewed here, I was like, so do you guys dog food? Do you hire your graduates in the engineering team? And I was really pleased that the answer was yes. But, yeah, he's been great. So, I mean, these hyper-motivated folks
可以非常快地完成它。但我认为艾伦（Alan）说过他每天花大约三个小时在这上面。所以，我的意思是，两端都有极端情况。嗯，我的意思是，这并不是不合理的。我的意思是，我确信有人在玩《英雄联盟》或者……你为什么非要点我的名？我还以为你是玩《Dota》的呢。
can get it done really quickly. But I think Alan said that he was spending like three hours a day on it. So, I mean, extremes on both ends. Well, I mean, which isn't unreasonable. I mean, I'm sure there are people playing League of Legends or... Why do you have to call me out on this? I thought you were a Dota guy.
是的，那倒是真的。好吧，好吧。所以，你自己暴露了。但是，你知道，《英雄联盟》或者，你知道，《反恐精英》，或者，你知道，《光环》。我要暴露年龄了。我不知道，随便什么吧。但无论如何，你知道，人们每天玩那个两三个小时，轻而易举，对吧？我的意思是，公平地说，我不是说他们在浪费时间，因为你可以随心所欲地支配自己的时间。
Yeah, that's true. Okay, well, okay. So, just out yourself then. But, you know, League of Legends or, you know, Counter-Strike or, you know, Halo. I'm going to date myself. I don't know, whatever. But anyways, you know, people playing that two, three hours a day, easy, right? I mean, to be fair, I'm not saying they're wasting their time because you do what you want with your time.
你绝对可以在一年内完成它。是的，我的意思是，学习两到三个小时可能比玩三小时《英雄联盟》还要难。这并不是荒谬的。是的，绝对的。Dota太棒了。玩那个游戏的人技术太高超了。我很难玩Dota，
You can absolutely finish it in a year. Yeah, I mean, two to3 hours studying is probably harder than playing League of Legends for 3 hours. It's not ridiculous. Yeah, absolutely. Dota is so good. People who play that are so skilled. It's hard for me to play Dota
因为我以前非常厉害，然后我们两个都有了孩子，所以现在我们不怎么玩了。当我又开始玩时，它仍然认为我和以前在同一个水平。所以现在我一玩，人们基本上就会辱骂我并让我滚开。不过我刚才没有真正回答你的问题。所以我们在网站上告诉人们的数据是每周10小时，持续六个月。但是再次强调，那是……
because I used to be very good and then we both had kids and so now we don't play that much anymore. And when I do play, it still thinks I'm at the same level. So now I play, and people basically call me slurs and tell me to leave. But I didn't really answer your question earlier. So what we tell people on the website is it's 10 hours a week for six months. But again, that's...
这很大程度上取决于个人。是的，这只是一个指导方针。正如你所说，我的意思是，如果你有一个人是化学工程师，那将与那些完成计算机科学学位四分之三却因生活变故而退学的人有所不同，对吧？这两个人的体验会有很大差异。所以你们有什么公开的统计数据吗？我的意思是，我知道保就业那个功能是相对较新的。而这个Flipkart的合作听起来甚至更新，但从历史上看，有没有关于——你知道的，学生的统计数据，比如漏斗模型是什么样的？比如来到这里的学生中，
It's very dependent. Yeah, this is a guideline. Like you said, I mean, if you have someone who's a chemical engineer, it's going to be different than someone who got three quarters of a way and for life circumstances dropped out of a computer science degree, right? Like those two people are going to have very different experiences. So do you have any public stats? I mean, I know that the guarantee thing is relatively new. And this Flipkart thing sounds like it's even newer but historically are there any stats on um you know students sort of like what the funnel looks like right like students who come in um sort of what percentage of them like finish what percentage like do you
有什么百分比的人完成了？有什么百分比的人——你们有没有什么很酷的成功案例之类的东西？嗯，全部。好吧。我想这期节目就到这里了。所以，是的，我们有超过2,000名毕业生。微学位是在2014年10月推出的。所以大约是16个月。所以我们有超过2,000名毕业生。关于就业的数据要难一些。我们帮助找到工作的人、我们所了解的人超过了300人。但我们预计这更多是一个自主上报的数据。
have any like cool success stories kind of things like that um yes all. Good. I guess that's it for this episode. So, yeah, we have over 2,000 graduates. And so the inter-degree is launched in October of 2014. So it's about 16 months. And so we have over 2,000 graduates. And the jobs thing is a little harder. People that we've helped put in jobs, people that we know about, is over 300. But we expect that they're more of a just, it's a self-reporting thing.
也有人因为这个获得了晋升。谷歌有一位女性从分析师转成了SWE（软件工程师）。好的。这需要技术面试。对，SWE就是软件工程师。你可能不知道。是的。我刚才说SWE，搞得真的很……所以，是的，另一个——还有什么数字是你问的？所以是成功案例，还有——是的，比如有没有什么特定的人说过什么让人印象深刻的话，比如：我当时离开是因为我不得不去阿富汗或者别的什么地方。我回来了。
And there are people that we know have gotten promotions, too, as a result of this. There was a woman at Google that went from being an analyst to being an SWE. Okay. Which requires a technical interview. Yeah, SWE is software engineer. you will not know. Yeah. I just said sweet and made it really. So yeah, the, what was the other, there was one other number you asked for. So success stories and also just, yeah, like anyone in particular who said something that kind of really Like, I was away because I had to go to Afghanistan or something. I came back.
我没法上大学。有没有什么像这样的酷炫故事？所以，是的，我最喜欢的是艾伦（Alan），也就是我刚才跟你提到的那个家伙。所以他曾是特种部队的成员。你这么说真有意思，因为他曾在阿富汗。他实际上做到了。他去了麻省理工学院（MIT）攻读机械工程。然后他加入了——在阿富汗。他真的做到了。他去了MIT攻读机械工程，然后他加入了军队。
I couldn't go to college. Any cool stories like that? So, yeah, my favorite is actually Alan, the guy I was telling you about earlier. So he was the special forces guy. And it's funny that you said that because he was in Afghanistan. He actually did. He went to MIT for mechanical engineering. And then he joined in Afghanistan. He actually did. He went to MIT for mechanical engineering, and then he joined the Army,
我没能上大学。有什么类似的有意思的故事吗？所以，是的，我最喜欢的是艾伦，也就是我刚才跟你提到的那个人。他是个特种兵。你这么说很有趣，因为他在阿富汗。他真的去过。他去麻省理工学院学了机械工程。然后他加入了阿富汗。他真的去过。他去麻省理工学院学了机械工程，然后加入了陆军，
did several deploys in Afghanistan, and came back and decided that he wanted to be a software engineer and just started doing nanodegrees, like I said, very rapidly, and then decided instead of getting a job, he was going to start his own company. And he started this really cool...
他在阿富汗执行过几次部署任务，回来后决定成为一名软件工程师，就像我说的，开始非常迅速地修读纳米学位，然后他决定不去找工作，而是自己创业。他创办了这个非常酷的……
The idea was crowdsourced insurance. Okay. So basically going back to the, you know, the idea behind insurance is distributed risk. Right. But like now you pick the people that you distribute risk with. Oh, okay, okay. So it's a totally fascinating model. So I'm imagining a Kickstarter page where it's like,
这个想法是众包保险。好的。基本上就是回到，你知道的，保险背后的理念是分摊风险。对吧。但现在是由你来选择与谁分摊风险。哦，好的，好的。所以这是一个完全迷人的模式。因此我想象了一个Kickstarter众筹页面，上面写着，
hi, I'm an athletic 30-year-old looking for other people. God smoker. Yeah. So the idea is like all of you get together and you say, okay, if I break my arm, we'll all split it, you know, in ways. Well, is it, well, okay. Let him finish the story. Then we can have some. Sorry, sorry.
嗨，我是一个30岁的运动型青年，正在寻找其他人。上帝啊，烟民。是的。所以这个想法是，你们所有人聚在一起，然后说，好吧，如果我摔断了手臂，我们都会分摊费用，你知道的，以某种方式。好吧，是，好吧。让他把故事讲完。然后我们可以发表一些。抱歉，抱歉。
That is an amazing business. Yeah. And novel, too. I was really surprised. So the, but anyway, he wound up interviewing here after he'd been doing that for about six months. And we were all just blown away in the interview process. Of course, we have a soft spot for our students, our graduates, obviously. But yeah, I hired him on the team, and he's just been incredible.
那真是一个了不起的业务。是的。而且也很新颖。我真的很吃惊。所以，但不管怎样，他在做了大约六个月之后，最后来到这里面试。我们在面试过程中都惊呆了。当然，我们对我们的学员、我们的毕业生自然有一种偏爱。但是，是的，我把他招进了团队，他简直太不可思议了。
And it's kind of, you know, people get jobs other places than Udacity, but that one's so close. And it's really amazing to see this guy every day was he able to hit the ground running or was it just okay I really need someone to boot camp me on Udacity or something no he didn't need a lot cool he's a it's definitely you know as an individual he's the sort of person that just runs really hard. And then I was talking about mock interviews earlier. It was sort of my introduction to the Udacity culture. I'd been here about a month, and I volunteered to do one of these mock interviews. And as we were talking about earlier, it was really satisfying to do it and then give her feedback.
而且这有点像，你知道的，人们除了优达学城（Udacity）还在别的地方找到工作，但那个太近了。而且看到这个人每天都这样真的太神奇了，他是一上岗就能直接进入状态，还是仅仅觉得，好吧，我真的需要在优达学城或其他地方接受一下训练营式的突击培训？不，他不需要太多，太酷了。他绝对是，你知道的，作为个人，他是那种干劲十足的人。然后我刚才谈到了模拟面试。这有点像我接触优达学城文化的开始。我来这里大约一个月了，我自愿去做这些模拟面试之一。正如我们刚才所讨论的，做完这些然后给她反馈，真的非常有满足感。
And this was a woman who was completely changing careers. She was like a court reporter. Okay. And this was a woman who was completely changing careers. She was like a court reporter and then was going to interview. She was interviewing around the valley for engineering test positions or software reliability engineer type things. And I didn't mention earlier, but I used to be at Nest. It's relevant to this story. So about five weeks later, she didn't tell me where she was interviewing. About five weeks later, I just get this gushing email thanking me for my help.
这是一个完全转行的女性。她之前好像是个法庭书记员。好的。而这是一个完全转行的女性。她以前好像是个法庭书记员，然后要去参加面试。她当时在湾区到处面试工程测试岗位或软件可靠性工程师一类的工作。我刚才没提，但我以前在Nest工作过。这和这个故事有关。所以大约五 weeks（周）后，她没有告诉我她在哪里面试。大约五周后，我突然收到了这封热情洋溢的邮件，感谢我的帮助。
And she just got a job on the integration engineering team at Nest. Cool. And there was something so appealing about seeing this person. For me as an individual, we do this at scale. But seeing the sort of impact on one person's life and um what was amazing but yeah we have lots of people we had somebody that was a pro golfer and decided they want to be a programmer and went to udacity and got a job as a programmer cool cool yeah there's where i used to work there were lots of programmers who did golfing but around here i don't know many people
然后她刚刚在Nest的集成工程团队找到了一份工作。太酷了。看到这个人有一种难以抗拒的吸引力。对作为个体的我来说，我们在做大规模的事情。但看到对某个人的生活产生的那种影响，嗯，最神奇的是，是的，我们有很多人，我们曾有过一个职业高尔夫球手，决定想成为一名程序员，于是去了优达学城，最后找到了一份程序员的工作，太酷了，太酷了。是的，在我以前工作的地方，有很多程序员都打高尔夫球，但在这附近，我不太认识很多人。
that's true it usually goes the other way around You want to become a pro golfer after you do programming. So before we go to some of the listener questions I think you have here. I don't know if we, I think we covered almost everything. Okay, I was going to say, so we talked a lot about Udacity, but I mean other things too, just being, you know, you said you were director of engineering. Is that your title? Did I get that right?
这倒也是，通常情况刚好相反。你做完编程后想去当职业高尔夫球手。所以在我们讨论你这里列出的一些听众提问之前，我想问，我不知道我们，我觉得我们几乎涵盖了所有内容。好吧，我本来想说，所以我们讨论了很多关于优达学城的内容，但我的意思是还有其他事情，比如作为一个，你知道的，你刚才说你是工程总监。这是你的头衔吗？我没弄错吧？
You know, what are the kinds of things, you know, just want people to know or whatever regarding Udacity, regarding, hey, when you're interviewing, don't brush your teeth before you go. Right. We always do. Or just good tips. You do obviously a lot of hiring, I imagine. I do.
你知道，大家想要了解的或者不管什么内容，关于优达学城的，关于，嘿，当你去面试时，去之前别刷牙。对吧。我们总是这么做。或者只是好的建议。显然你想象得出你做了很多招聘工作。我确实做。
Or at least a lot of interviewing. And so, yeah. So if you want to talk a little bit about that, people are always asking us for tips, right? We have people who are already kind of training or trained to be computer science now they're trying to do interviews so like that stuff is also um would be interesting for people to hear and then i i read a blog post in preparation for this where you were right talking about being a dad in the as a programmer i think okay you're looking at a little blank it's like uh-oh no no
或者至少做了很多面试。所以，是的。如果你想稍微谈谈这个，人们总是向我们索要建议，对吧？我们有一些人已经接受了或者正在接受计算机科学的培训，现在他们正试图参加面试，所以这类事情也，嗯，对大家来说会很有趣，然后我为了做准备读了一篇博客文章，你在那篇文章里谈到作为一个程序员同时也是个父亲，我想，好吧，你看上去有点茫然，就像是，呃哦，不，不。
um and so we're both that so you know if we want to talk about that or diversity in the work for like these are things we care about as well So if you just kind of have any other things that you want to talk about or give tips or... Yeah, we've been kind of blasting you with questions now as you're talking to... To blast you guys with questions? No, I think on the interviewing, it's obvious, but so many people get it wrong,
嗯，所以我们俩都是父亲，所以你知道，如果我们想谈论这个，或者职场多元化，比如这些也是我们在乎的事情。所以如果你还有任何其他想谈论的事情或者想给出的建议，或者……是的，我们在你说话的时候一直在向你抛出各种问题……向你们抛出问题吗？不，我认为在面试方面，这很明显，但有太多人弄错了，
is ask questions. You know, the big thing, the mistake that I see people make, and this is experienced people as well, is that they come, the mistake that I see people make, and this is like experienced people as well, is that they come to the interview and you set up a problem
那就是提问。你知道，我看到人们犯的最大错误，而且这也是有经验的人常犯的错误，就是他们来面试时，你给他们出了一道题，
for them and they just go, okay, right. And they don't ask you whether you care more about time or space or, you know, just, and that's always
然后他们就直接说，好的，对吧。他们根本不问你更关心时间复杂度还是空间复杂度，你知道的，仅仅是，这始终是一个
a red flag. I don't know about you guys, but for me, that's always this red flag of like, no clarifying questions at all. And,
危险信号。我不知道你们怎么看，但对我来说，这总是一个危险信号，比如根本没有澄清问题。而且，
that's the advice I want to give to almost, well, not almost, but to lots of candidates. If I had the chance, just ask me questions before you start answering the question. Yeah, I mean, imagine if you're on the job and someone says, I want you, we're building the next Facebook.
这就是我想对几乎所有人，好吧，不几乎是所有人，而是对许多候选人给出的建议。如果我有机会，请在开始回答问题之前先向我提问。是的，我的意思是，想象一下如果你在工作岗位上，有人对你说，我希望你，我们正在构建下一个Facebook。
You always hear this. I get asked this on Quora every week. How do I build the next Facebook? So if someone comes to you on the job and says, hey, you'll build the next Facebook, your answer would be why? I mean, like, what's really the point here? Or if not why, at least, like, how? Like, what sort of assumptions are we making that's going to make things different, right?
你总是听到这种说法。我每周在Quora上都会被问到这个问题。我如何构建下一个Facebook？所以如果在工作中有人来找你并说，嘿，你要构建下一个Facebook，你的回答会是为什么？我的意思是，比如，这到底有什么意义？或者如果不问为什么，至少也要问，怎么做？比如，我们做出了什么样假设，才能让事情变得不同，对吧？
And it's the same in an interview. If someone says, you know, do a deep copy of this graph, you should say, well, is it a tree or does it have cycles in the graph? Like these kind of things, right? You should ask questions back to them and start to understand. And then also just ask about the company and is it sort of the right place to be. I totally agree. That would be one of my top things is people just want to know. There's plenty of people who can do the deep copy of the graph. There's not that many people who are
面试也是一样。如果有人说，你知道的，对这个图进行深拷贝（deep copy），你应该说，嗯，它是一棵树，还是图中有环？像这样的一些问题，对吧？你应该反问他们并开始去理解。然后还可以询问关于公司的事，以及这是否是一个正确的地方。我完全同意。这将是我的首要事情之一，人们只是想知道。有很多人能够对图进行深拷贝。但是没有那么多的人是
genuinely interested in the company that you're representing. I'll give a dissenting opinion because I really had this argument yesterday at work. And so there is a fine balance here between uh people who stall by asking questions sure and then when you're doing an interview trying to make it clear that you're not so like i know this and i'm ready to go and so sometimes people ask questions which are simple enough that they don't i won't say don't require because as you said you may could ask something but they're trying to look let's put up a solution and then like i want to show I can get a solution up, and then let's talk about it. Because often as engineers, I mean, that's kind of, you first say, how would I solve this as a first order thing, and then talk about, now that I have a, you know, something down, especially if I know it's going to be short
真正对你所代表的公司感兴趣。我来发表一个不同的意见，因为我昨天在工作时刚刚争论过这个。所以这里存在一种微妙的平衡，介于那些通过提问来拖延时间的人（当然），以及你在面试时试图表现得明确——表明你不是在拖延——之间，比如：我知道这个，我已经准备好了。所以有时人们会问一些足够简单的问题，它们并不——我不会说“不需要”，因为正如你所说，你可能会问一些东西——但他们试图展现出来：让我们先提出一个解决方案，然后，就像我想要展示我能够拿出一个解决方案，然后我们再来讨论。因为通常作为工程师，我的意思是，那就是，你首先会说，作为第一优先级的核心，我会如何解决这个问题，然后讨论：既然我已经有了一个，你知道的，已经落地写出来的东西，特别是如果我知道它会足够短，我可以快速搞定它——那么我们来讨论一下会有什么不同，对吧？我并不是说你们是错的，我只是说，我曾遇到过这样的候选人：我抛出一个简单初阶的问题，而他们想要阐述时却直接给出了答案。我实际上并不会因此扣他们的分，因为随后我会说，好的，那很棒。如果他们速度够快，或者速度较慢，我会稍微拦住他们一下，等等，听着，你知道的，不管怎样，他们快速敲代码，很好，做到最后然后说：啊，太棒了，现在如果我们这样改变或者那样改变会发生什么？然后我开始引入这些。
enough that I can bang it out fast, like, let's talk about what would be different, right? And I'm not saying you guys are wrong, I'm just saying, like, I've had candidates who I ask a simple first question and I want to expound upon they go ahead and give me an answer I don't actually knock them down for that because then I say okay now that was great and if they're going fast enough they're going slow enough I'll kind of stop them away hang on a second like you know whatever they're banging out fast great get to the end and say ah that's great now what happens if we change it this way or change it right and now I begin to introduce that
或者有时他们甚至会问，一旦他们完成了第一件事，哦，你是说可以用这种方法解决的东西吗？然后给出五行代码，结果发现，哦，对，那会是一个解决方案。然后就像，好的，好吧，发生了什么？你喜欢吗？你打算这样改吗？你打算那样改吗？他们在那个时候问我，因为我会说，当有人不这样做时，我非常谨慎地认为这是一个危险信号，因为……好观点。我明白你的意思。总的来说这是一个有效的观点。面试中几乎没有什么绝对的事情。它是非常即兴的。
or maybe sometimes they even ask like once they get that first thing up oh you mean something that's solvable by this and give me five lines of code and it's like well yeah that would be a solution and then like okay well what happened do you like are you planning to change this are you planning to change that and they asked me at that point because i would say i'm very careful to say that when someone doesn't do this thing i it's a red flag because... That's a good point. I understand what you're saying. It's a valid point in general. There are hardly any absolutes in interviewing. It's very improvisational.
只是我过去几年一直遇到的是，人们直接跳进问题里却漏掉了关键点。但有时真的很明显，如果你已经设置好了问题，也许这不是一个好的问题。我们可以讨论这个。
It's just the thing that I've been running into the last couple years is just people just jumping into problems and missing a key. But sometimes it's really blatant if you've set the problem up, which maybe it's not a good question. We could get to that.
这是一个单独的讨论，但有些人开始做某事时却漏掉了某些东西。是的。对吧。所以你有时会推进得很远，你可以开始着手，但你会达到某种程度然后卡住，现在你就会陷入困境，因为你做了假设，结果还是没能搞定。那是，在这种情况下你有吗？是的。
It's a separate discussion, but some people start something with something missing. Yeah. Right. And so you will get some far, you can get started, but you'll get to some point and be stuck and now you'll be hosed because you made assumptions and then you still couldn't get it done. And that's, do you have in that case? Yeah.
你是否有某种，所以我们过去曾分享过我们的面试恐怖故事，所以这是硬币的两面，你知道，一个令人毛骨悚然的面试，以及面试别人时发生了可怕的事情。你在哪一边遇到过面试恐怖故事吗？我很高兴你问了。哦，不，是的。所以当我在湾区的一家公司时，嗯，我是作为招聘经理去面试的，所以我通常会问一些行为面试问题，你知道的，只是看一看，这个人能和别人合作得好吗？但我总是会抛出一个技术问题，这是一个健全性检查（sanity check），在那段时间里，这个题目是，这些只是类似FizzBuzz类型的问题。对吧，是的，而且它只是一道FizzBuzz——FizzBuzz是最流行的面试题，但实际上，我从来没见过任何人问过它。
Do you have sort of like a, so we've shared in the past the past our interview horror stories so this is on both sides of the fence you know an interview that was that was horrifying and interviewing someone else where horrifying things happened did you have an interview horror story on either side i'm so glad you asked oh no yes so while i was at a company in the valley um and i was interviewing as a hiring manager so I would typically do behavioral questions and just you know looking at you know will this person work well with other people but I would always throw a technical question and this is a sanity check and for a while there the one and these are just kind of fizzbuzz type question okay yeah and it was just filled on a fizzbuzz is like the most popular interview question but it's really I've never seen anyone ask it
我也没见过，但这是最经典的例子，这是最经典的示例问题，但我甚至不知道它是什么，是带有for循环还是什么的，它的一个版本是：我希望你打印fizz，你知道的，通过一个计数器，打印出数字1、2、3以及所有内容，每逢第七个数字就说fizz（译者注：原文如此，实际规则通常为3的倍数说fizz，5的倍数说buzz），或者每逢第三个数字说buzz，每逢第七个数字说fizz。然后这就是问题。并且你要确定，在那些
before I haven't either but it's the most example it's the most example question but I don't even know it is something with a for loop or something if a version of it is I want you to print fizz you know go through a counter and print out to number one two three and everything every seventh safe is every third say or every third say buzz, every seventh say fizz. And then that's the question. And you're supposed to determine that on ones that
既是7又是3的公倍数时，你需要说fizz, buzz。好的，明白了。这就是要点。所以你问了一个FizzBuzz问题。或者类似于FizzBuzz的问题。那个问题实际上是计算32位整数中设置的位数（1的个数）。这个家伙，他是法国人，所以我打算在这里模仿一下。
are common multiples of seven and three, you need to say fizz, buzz. OK, got it. That's the gist. So you asked a fizz, buzz question. Or similar to the fizz, buzz question. The question was actually count the number of set bits in a 32-bit integer. And this guy, he was French, so I'm going to try to do an impression here.
这家伙把身子往椅子后背一靠，这在视频里可没用。完全是一种傲慢的态度。肢体语言糟透了。他就是靠在椅背上。他用一种蔑视的眼神看着白板，然后他说，你可以看出这是一家涉及位操作的硬件公司。
This guy kind of leans back in his chair, which doesn't work on video. It's just total attitude. Body language is awful. He's just leaning back in the chair. He's got this contemptuous look at the whiteboard. And he's like, you can tell it's a leaning back in the chair. He has this contemptuous look at the whiteboard and he's like, you can tell it is a hardware company with the bits.
而我说，不，不，这是一个解决问题的事情。第一原则是没有问题。我们只是过一遍，而他却越来越生气。就在我准备叫停的时候，我心里想，好吧，算了吧。我们不做这道题了。他大喊：那些位！我好几年没用过那些位了！
And I'm like, no, no, this is a problem solving thing. First principle is no problem. We just walk through it and he's just getting angry. And right when I'm about to call it, and I'm just like, okay, forget about it. We won't do this question. He yells, the bits! I have not used the bits in years
然后他抓起背包，冲了出去。哦，哦！所以这是立刻录用吗？是的，听起来很棒，快把那家伙拉过来，老兄，那太惊人了。哦，老兄，所以答案是查表法。太痛苦了，对吧？就像这样。所以，所以，其中的一件事是……我现在要做这道题了。我会说……在直播中。太迷人了。最难的事情，对我作为一个面试者来说最可怕的事情，
and then he picks up his backpack and storms oh oh my so is it instant hire yeah sounds great get that guy around man that's amazing oh man so the answer is look up table that's painful right like that so so well, one of the things there is... I'm going to do the problem now. I'll say like... On air. Fascinating. The hardest thing, the most frightening thing for me as an interviewee,
有人问我：你会如何为这个网站设计数据库？那是一家网站公司。而我只懂嵌入式系统，当时我对网络一无所有，呃，然后我基本上说了各种各样的话，他们说：哦，那行不通。我说：嗯，我想你是对的，你知道的。而且，呃，这里重要的事情是，呃，一定要试着边说边把思路理清，并进行重要的对话。我的意思是，正如你所说，我的意思是，也许这家伙知道答案，但因为他不想进行对话，
somebody asked me, how would I design a database for this website? And it was a website company. And I only knew embedded systems i know anything about web anything at the time and uh and i basically kind of said various things they said oh it's not going to work i was like yeah i guess you're right you know and and uh the important thing there is uh it is always try and talk your way through it and have an important dialogue i mean as you said i mean this is maybe this guy knew the answer, but because he didn't want to have the dialogue,
你永远不会通过这种方式得到这份工作。你的恐怖故事中的另一个有用的提示是，即使你参加的是技术面试，也要做好准备，当有人说“告诉我你解决过的一个问题”，或者“用几句话介绍一下你自己”，或者“用两个词来形容你”时，不要当场愣住。它会说，哦，这些问题很简单，如果你没有花几分钟时间考虑一下，你就会被打得
you're never gonna get the job that way. The other useful tip in your horror story is, even if you're going for a tentacle interview, be ready, don't fall over when someone says, tell me about a problem you solved, or tell me about yourself in a few sentences, or two words to describe you. It says, oh, those are questions that are easy, if you've not like spent a few minutes thinking about it you'll be caught
措手不及，这会变得很尴尬，而且你可以，呃，通过攻读纳米学位来提高所有这些技能，我知道，但我是，我其实只是，我可以展示，哇，哇，杰森，我能说什么呢？球瓶已经摆好了，我只需要把它们击倒就行了。由你赞助，丹。不，但我想说的是，我们举行这些问答，它们叫什么来着？空中视频群聊（Hangouts on air）。哦，好吧。是的。我们会在那里现场解答面试问题。
flat-footed and it gets awkward and you can uh improve all of these skills by doing the nano degree i know but i was i was actually just i can show wow wow jason what can i say is the pins were set up i just had to knock them down. Sponsored by you, Dan. No, but I was going to say that we do these sort of question and answer, what are they called? Hangouts on air. Oh, okay. Yeah. Where we'll just field interview questions.
而且，我的意思是，每个问题最常见的回答都是，你知道的，准备。你知道的，你刚才暗示的，别，别被行为面试问题难倒。你可以预料到那些，对吧。只要练习，你知道的，在一个月内和优达学城的工程师一起练习。但我以为你想说的是，你允许人们问你面试问题，然后就像有人解决了这个问题，感觉：太有魄力了。太有魄力了。哇。因为每次我……我们不那样做，但现在我们会了。这真的是个好主意。我现在有点想听这个了。我能打个电话问一些问题吗？
And, I mean, the most common answer to every question is, you know, prep. You know, what you were alluding to is,, don't, don't get stumped by, you know, behavioral questions. You can expect those, right. And just practice and, you know, practice with the Udacity engineer during a month. But I thought you were going with that is that you allow people to ask you interview questions and then like someone solves that was like, that is gutsy. That is gutsy. Wow. Cause every time I... We don't do that, but now we will. That's a really good idea. I kind of want to listen to this now. Can I call in with some questions?
我想我不知道怎么解决。我有这个bug。我能直接把这个源代码发给你吗？它变成了一些源代码，这真的很不幸。我试图训斥那些被我抓到这样做的学员，但是，比如，虐待面试者。就像，你知道的，问他们一些荒谬的问题。而且，比如，你并不指望他们能答好，但就像你问他们一个超级难的问题，
I guess I don't know how to solve. I have this bug. Can I just send you this source code? It becomes some source, and this is really unfortunate. I try to fuss at people I catch doing it, but, like, abuse the interviewee. Like, you know, ask them some question that's ridiculous. And, like, you don't expect them to do well, but like you ask them a really hard question
只是为了像展示一样。这很值得一提。所以你听说过这个。实际上，我认为这在金融界是真实的。我有一个朋友，他曾在一家，嗯，特定的金融公司面试。他们有一场面试，就是试图激怒你，
just to like show like it. That's worth saying. So you hear about this. And actually, I think this is true in the finance sector. I have a friend who interviewed at, well, a certain finance company. And they have an interview where they just try and get under your skin
然后看你如何反应。所以总的来说，我的意思是，我曾在许多公司面试过别人，也担任过面试官。我从未见过这种情况。哦，我见过。真的吗？你见过面试的目的是为了……是的，有人，嗯，我不知道他们是不是……有人在面试进行到15分钟时对我说，
and see how you react. So in general, I mean, I've interviewed and been an interviewer at a lot of companies. I've never seen this. Oh, I have. Really? You've seen an interview where the point was to... Yeah, someone, well, I don't know that they were... Someone told me 15 minutes into an interview,
我认为你没有任何技术技能。当时我正在解决一个技术问题，比如在白板上。但我的重点是，他们这样做并不是为了真正告诉你什么，他们只是太糟糕了。我的意思是，我想他们那天气色不好，可能那是一个糟糕的日子。大多数地方这都是人力资源部门（HR）介入的时刻，对吧？所以，不，我不能确定那是一个测试，这不可能知道。但确实有些被告知要问候选人的面试官，我知道确实有这回事，
I think you have no technical skills whatsoever. When I was solving a technical problem, like on the whiteboard. But my point is they weren't know to tell you that really that they were just a terrible I mean they're having a bad day I think they're having a bad day probably that's an HR moment most places yeah so no I don't know that for sure it was a test it's impossible to know but it is true that some people are told ask the candidate, and I do know this
问他们一个超级难的问题，然后你们内部有一个标尺，预计他们只能答出简单的部分或者答到一半，他们想确保至少有一个问题不是完全可以被解决的，这样你们就知道上限在哪里。在编程竞赛中也是如此，对吧？
ask them a really hard question and then you have a calibration internally that they're only expected to get the easy answer or halfway through and they want to make sure that at least one question isn't completely solvable so you know where the upper limit is that's true in programming competitions as well, right?
就像有些题目你本来就不应该在规定时间内解答出来。这就是为什么东欧的ACM题集比世界总决赛的题集更难。因为有太多来自东欧赛区的队伍无法晋级。因为每个赛区只有前三名队伍晋级。他们发现，当他们把这两套题集做得一样难时，每个人都——不是每个人，但很多人都把所有题都答对了，所以他们最终不得不把那套题集变得更难，所以你是对的，我的意思是面试也是一样的，他们必须确保你不可能把所有题都答对，因为他们想知道
Like there's some you're really not supposed to be able to answer in the timeframe. That's why the Eastern European ACM set is harder than the World Finals set. Because there's so many teams from the Eastern European division that don't qualify. Because only the top three teams from each division qualify. And they found that when they made those two sets the same everyone got a not everyone but a lot of people got all of them right and so they ended up having to make that set harder and so you're right I mean interviews are the same way where they keep they need to make sure that you can't get everything right so that because they want to know
当你感到局促不安时会发生什么，对吧？而且并不是为了达到虐待的程度，你可以避开HR介入的时刻，作为招聘经理，你必须非常信任进行面试的那个人，让他们这么做。仅仅因为你在A问题上表现不佳，并不意味着你真的表现不佳，B问题可能意味着它就是设计成让你无法完成的。
where you're what happens when you write squirm right and not to an abusive point you can avoid HR moments and you have to be really trusting of the person doing the interview as a hiring manager to tell them to do this. Just because you're doing poorly on a problem A, doesn't mean you're actually doing poorly and B, may mean it's designed for you not to finish.
无论如何，我想我把我们带偏了。你刚才在谈论金融界的这个人。不，我认为有些面试，有些公司，他们，呃，有些人们认为那家公司会给你难堪，但这不是真的，他们其实只是在寻找最好的人才，而且，呃，呃，当你面试时，你们双方的目标是一致的，这是需要从中汲取的一个重要观点，但是，呃，太酷了，谢谢你，阿特。哦，谢谢你的时间，呃，这太棒了。好吧，呃，我真的很期待，呃，得到反馈，所以我们可能会从听众那里收到一些关于你的问题，
Anyways, I think I derailed us. You were saying about this person in the finance. No, I think there's some interviews that were some companies where they uh there's there's like people think that that company they try to give you a hard time but it's not true they're really just trying to find the best people and uh um and you're all you're both kind of have aligned interests when you're interviewing that's one important thing to take away but uh cool thank you art oh thank you for your time uh this is awesome well uh i'm really looking forward to uh to uh to um getting the feedback and so we might get some questions for
这样我们就可以把它们转达给你，诸如此类的事情，听起来不错。太酷了。我想就这样了。谢谢大家收听，呃，片头音乐是Binary Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0协议下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及进行混音和改编。但你必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。
you from from the listeners so we can send them your way and things like that and sounds good cool i guess that's it thank you guys for listening and uh the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work. But you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自听众的反馈，这样我们可以把这些联系方式发给你之类的话，听起来不错，酷，我想就这些了，谢谢大家的收听。片头音乐是 biner pilot 的 axo。Programming Throwdown 采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议授权。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输本作品，以及进行重混和改编。但您必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式分享。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。